call elliott page dumb as a more
suitable insult from you it's like you
don't want to run around accusing people
of pride that's what depends on whether
they parade themselves on the cover of a
fashion magazine or not well you've
paraded yourself around plenty too yeah
but it wasn't to entice adolescent girls
to sterilize themselves
[Music]
hello everyone
i needed to write
and read a very careful intro to this
podcast episode as it deals with
particularly tricky and contentious
matters so please forgive the deviation
from spontaneity that such writing and
reading necessarily requires
the discussion that follows this intro
is as free-flowing as might be hoped for
if that is some consolation
in 2016
i released three videos on youtube
commentaries on a law being passed at
the federal level in canada bill c-16
purporting to grant protected status to
people with uncertain so-called gender
identities
but in my opinion constituting an
unwarranted intrusion into the socially
necessary and fundamentally important
domain of free speech
those videos went viral
for reasons that are still not exactly
clear
i believed at the time that the
introduction of confusion
regarding the conceptualization and
terminology of masculine and feminine
identity would produce far more trouble
than it would cure
more specifically that would produce a
psychogenic epidemic
among vulnerable young women around the
age of puberty
experiencing the onset of increased
negative emotion characteristic of that
age and sex this is exactly and
precisely what has happened and it's not
good and it has to stop
in any case
my objection in these videos and some
subsequent interviews most famously i
suppose with kathy newman of channel 4
news with joe rogan multiple times
with helen lewis of gq
as well as two books i wrote in recent
years in a lecture series on genesis
brought me to what has been increasingly
broad public attention that has been a
great adventure
with the attendant cost of severe and
often exceptionally caustic criticism
i have now talked with at least a
hundred people
who have also been made into public
targets
without exception it has struck them to
the core put their careers at risk
alienated them too often from family and
friends
and driven not a few into psychiatric
care or wards
everyone mobbed reacts as if they have
contracted a potentially fatal illness
and the social media environment we now
inhabit enables those who are prone to
form mobs
to do so with ease and impunity
this also has to stop
but who is at fault
who should stop
this is a hard question i've been
criticized for my own online behavior
many people have told me that i've been
too harsh particularly in tone
particularly when reading articles about
political or cultural issues that have
also been typically published in
newspaper form and i have found myself
in substantive trouble as a consequence
of twitter
at the moment
the college of psychologists of ontario
which is the governing body of such
professionals
has seen fit to launch an investigation
into ten or so complaints that's ten
separate investigations by the way that
have been levied against me because of
what i have said on that oft
pathological snake pit of a platform
now it is true that such governing
bodies have become appallingly corrupt
in recent years
on the medical legal and psychological
fronts anyone anywhere in the world can
levy a complaint against me
as a psychologist for any reason
whatsoever and i have no right to face
my accuser and the college can make life
very difficult for me on the legal
financial and professional front as they
have done continuously for the last six
years
even though they have the option of
dismissing such complaints as frivolous
and vexatious which they most certainly
are
but it is also the case the twitter
suspended my account quite recently for
violating their community standards
whatever they are
a ruling which i appealed so far
unsuccessfully as despite the publicity
around my suspension twitter has yet to
respond to my objection
this does not surprise me
i suspect that the formal reason for the
suspension
is that i dead named elliot page
which is the act of referring to a
person who has decided that they are the
sex alternate to their fundamental
biological identity by the name given to
them at birth and used until their
so-called transition this has become a
cardinal sin by the standards of the
radical gender bending social
constructionists who have made mobbing a
veritable act of
expertise my family has also cautioned
me against my twitter use believing with
some real justification that it causes
more trouble than good
the evidence contrary to that i suppose
is that i have nearly three million
followers who appear to believe that my
tweets have some redemptive utility and
the fact that i can use twitter to keep
an eye on the currents in the general
culture learn how the platform works and
affects society in a broad sense and
follow the activities of the hundreds of
so-called influencers whom i have met
and talked with in the last six or seven
years it's a conundrum as i also find
the platform stressful
as the comments
often from the anonymous trolls who
specialize in caustic narcissistic
denigration are almost demonic in their
destructive men
similar cautions have been directed to
me although much less frequently about
the tone i use from time to time on
youtube
often when dealing with an issue that is
also publicly controversial
some of the contentious issues that
we're obsessed with in the modern world
such as pronoun use and the associated
blockades of puberty and surgical
mutilations or transformations depending
on your perspective and sterilizations
make me both afraid and angry
those emotions serve as motivations for
writing and public commentary but their
excessive expression produces the risk
of exacerbating the political
polarization and toxic social media
exchanges that appear to be polluting
our culture to a dangerous degree
and it's not just people who object to
my ideas or even my mere existence who
are criticizing it's people who broadly
support my endeavors but have some
troubles with the specifics here's some
examples from two high-level corporate
c-suite dwellers who fall into that
category
both of whom watched my recent so-called
message to ceos
first
dear jordan
although i agree with most of the
underlying substance of your argument
i'm not sure your approach is as
persuasive as it could be it feels more
like a mock fusilade at ceos addressed
to your fan base
rather than a message addressed to ceos
which might persuade them to change
their ways
in that sense i am not sure it will move
the dial of the debate
as you say most ceos do not have the
time for political or philosophical
debate nor understand the deep currents
that are driving dei and esg
they are hapless victims of long-dead
philosophers and economists but and it
is a big but they are mostly competent
people immersed in the detail of
implementing or not esg or dei
so the way to get to them is through the
details of the flaws in the various esg
taxonomies or the credibility of the
grifters peddling this stuff
second commentary
dear jordan when we first met i was
disoriented by your extension of trust
i knew immediately that i was speaking
to a real person
you provide the same experience for your
audience
it is a super power
that superpower could be described as a
unique combination of insight and
vulnerability
millions of people trust you because
they see raw unscripted emotion from a
real person seeking truth and without
the veil of a persona
ironically one of your greatest
strengths is this earnest generosity
with quote weakness
i fear
the ceo video loses the humble
vulnerability from the superpower
equation
i found myself hoping the non-judgmental
jordan peterson would appear
instead i got caught in a net of angry
sarcastic judgments
even with the patience that comes with
my respect for you i could not abstract
constructive value from the bitter tone
i found it hard
if i found it hard i cannot imagine
other ceos would respond positively
i recognize the ridiculous irony of
judging you for being too judgmental but
that in essence is the problem
the reflexive defensive response to
judgment is to judge
for example the message fails to
contemplate that ceos may tolerate some
noise because we know we can act
decisively
it also commits the leftist sin of
ascribing guilt to an entire group
your best lectures are genuine dialogues
you're both teacher and student
clinician and patient father and son
you are a fellow sinner helping us
analyze sin
consequently the audience is open to the
call to responsibility because they
trust deeply that you have similarly
admonished yourself
my belief is that people trust you
because your judgment is not judgmental
most of the time you attack the sin
not the sinner
i could be completely off if i have
misunderstood or misread this
i apologize
now these are very thoughtful criticisms
both written by men who are doing their
level best to help me
and everyone i am communicating with
separate the wheat from the chaff
i have been involved in many discussions
recently about the tone of the youtube
articles similar to those
that generated these comments
some people equally credible believe
that the tone of hypothetically
righteous outrage that i adopted at
least partly to harness the anger
necessary to broach the topics publicly
in the first place had a clearly
valuable place
others believed as did the ceos i cited
that i would be more effective
if i alienated fewer people
while offering my views
recently when reading an article i wrote
for the uk newspaper the telegraph
i tried something different responding
to the feedback i had received
i wrote an equally critical piece
back off old masters of the universe
directed at the consulting company
deloitte which in may of 2022 released a
globalist utopian missive
as part of a necessary effort to curb
economic growth
to save the planet
i was not very impressed by the deloitte
arguments or any similar arguments
predicated on the idea that some very
real and immediate suffering must be
necessarily imposed from the top down
on those who are struggling say in the
developing world
because there is no other way of
rectifying the biosphere
in any case independent of the merits of
that argument i attempted to manifest a
much calmer tone
less afraid less angry
that experiment which was a genuine
attempt to change appeared to be very
successful
i don't believe that doing so softened
the points i was making in any real
sense and i produced much less kickback
from my consultant compatriots
and from the intended audience who took
what i said with more seriousness rather
than less here are some representative
comments
taken from a youtube comment section
notable in this case for its positive
nature
first mr peterson i still love the
videos you've done before and re-watched
them on occasion but this one has
exactly the tone that is appropriate to
its content
second
i really appreciate the change in tone
these subjects can be hard to truly hear
speaking for myself while i do find it
important that it is heard
and this more neutral slash calm i'd say
factual approach makes it more
digestible for me this in turn makes it
easier for me to share this information
in a more calm factual manner
third
nothing in the message was lost by
stating the facts in a calm tone
thank you dr peterson for your effort
for practicing what you preach
for being a good example
live and learn
we hope
on the twitter front things are more
complex
i should point out as a bit of
background that since i emerged so to
speak in the public realm that i have
had many good critics helping me
maintain my equilibrium and working with
me to improve my capacity to communicate
these include family members my wife
tammy and two adult children michaela
and julian who are not afraid to tell me
what they think and who provide wise
counsel
as well as a stellar group of friends
and colleagues who are very competent
people and who do their best to tell me
when they think i'm deviating as i often
do
from the straight and narrow
these are all people who have some
serious concerns about the state of
modern society and hope i'm doing some
good and who would like in so far as
they are able to help me do better
that group
includes the two people i am talking
with on the video to which this missive
serves as introduction
jonathan pagio fine artist deep
religious thinker public intellectual
and friend
and greg hurwitz
author of popular commercial fiction
most notably the orphan x series comic
book writer political consultant former
student of mine some 30 years ago at
harvard
and friend
ever since
i've been speaking to herwitz about
everything under the sun during the
entire time we have known each other but
in more recent years that has become
more political i've been working with
greg with a group of strategists and
public communicators for the democratic
party in the u.s for more than six years
trying to pull the party to the middle
away from the leftist radicals with some
success
he has been a very able advocate
for the more liberal side of the
political spectrum and has helped me
immensely in my attempts to maintain
communication with people who occupy
that side whose worth and concerns i
understand
after all don't the dispossessed require
a voice
he voiced a series of objections to some
of my recent tweets including the
particular utterance that resulted in my
suspension and we spent some active and
contentious time privately going back
and forth about the propriety and
utility of my actions
i then asked him if he would be willing
to do so publicly
to serve in part as devil's advocate and
in part as a genuine voice of the
centrist left
in relation to my attempts to
communicate by social media
he had some concerns about doing so
criticizing me
something that is certainly necessary
brings with it a plethora of risks
including eliciting precisely that
mobbing behavior discussed previously
that is so unpleasant and damaging
criticizing me publicly also risks
exposing the critic to exactly the same
kind of criticism
can mr hurwitz do a better job while
pointing out the inadequacies of my
communicative strategy that i'm doing
when engaged in such communication
perhaps not
in which case he ends up in the same
boat but i asked him to do it and he
agreed
there is no way to improve without
thinking about improving and that
requires forthright discussion about
potential flaws of approach tone and
content
and i found the back and forth that you
will be privy to after this introduction
extremely useful
i asked mr jonathan pagio to participate
because he was in miami with greg and i
recently was listening to our private
conversation about such issues around
the dinner table and had many wise
things to say
he acts in what follows more as a
mediator and is someone who is assessing
the gist and clarifying and i would like
to thank him as well as greg for that
what tweets are we interrogating
there are three essentially or three
sets
the first involves the process by which
the nomination of supreme court justice
katanji brown jackson occurred
i was less than impressed
by this process which was initiated in
my opinion as the democrats themselves
indicated with the announcement that it
was time for a quote black woman to
occupy one of the highest judicial
positions in the land
here is a relevant tweet from the
democrats during his campaign for
president
president biden announced that he
planned to appoint a black woman to the
supreme court now judge katanji brown
jackson has been confirmed to our
nation's highest court he kept his
promise to the american people
this was followed up by commentary from
former white house press secretary jan
sackey as reported by reuters
this was an earlier uh tweet actually
president joe biden stands by his pledge
to nominate a black woman to the u.s
supreme court white house press
secretary jenn saki said and then
somewhat later
2022025 from president biden's twitter
account
i sought a nominee with the strongest
credentials record character and
dedication to the rule of law that's why
i'm excited to nominate judge katanji
brown jackson to serve on the united
states supreme court
to this i responded once again on
twitter
2022025 no you didn't referring to biden
you announced publicly that you would
limit the search to a specific race in
sex you eliminated the vast majority of
qualified candidates from consideration
and it is thereby virtually certain
technically that you failed to pick the
strongest candidate and then i capped it
off with this
when the nomination was announced well
this was 20 22 02 25. well
she looks like she can play the part and
that's what matters intersectionality
rules
competence is a ruse this caused a bit
of a firestorm not least among my
democrat conference the very people i
had been working with to pull the
policies of the party toward the middle
was it appropriate
opinions vary as you will find out if
you have the interest and patience
necessary to walk through the discussion
subsequent to this introduction
so that's one of three contentious
tweets
there were two others that we subjected
to interrogation
the first involved of all things
the sports illustrated swimsuit cover
girl yumi new a plus-sized model
featured prominently on that magazine's
most coveted spot
i regarded her photo shoot
as a ploy of politically correct
pandering cynicism on the part of sport
illustrated's marketers as a form of
exploitation brought about by the model
herself and by those who used her image
and
as an extension of the current culture
war raging about the definitions of such
things as female beauty
and i somewhat impulsively
that's twitter made my opinions
obliquely known
with the following tweet
sorry not beautiful
and no amount of authoritarian tolerance
is going to change that
this
was regarded by some as an entirely
justified reaction to some blatant
manipulation on the part of sports
illustrated and by others as an entirely
unwarranted attack on a vulnerable young
woman
greg and jonathan and i debate this
issue at length
the third tweet
and the message that resulted in my
suspension from that damnable but
compelling platform
involved elliot former ellen page
i was unimpressed let's say given the
current psychogenic epidemic raging in
relationship to so-called gender
identity with page's decision first to
surgically alter his or her body with
the collusion of the relevant physicians
and second
to trumpet the results of that
alteration in an extremely public manner
thus potentially enticing fragile young
people to in cautiously seek the same
hypothetical cure
this tweet resulted
remember when pride was a sin
and ellen page just had her breasts
removed by a criminal physician this may
be very popular and unpopular
in any case it is all this that is the
subject of the following youtube
discussion
i would ask all of you watching and
listening to have some patience if you
will as the conversation progresses and
to remember
that both mr hurwitz and mr paggio were
willing to put themselves on the line
publicly to help me learn and help me
improve my consequent public
presentation
i titled the episode
with the term apologia rather than
response to my critics or heaven forbid
apology because apologia has a very
specific meaning
here is how the merriam-webster
dictionary defines the word
apologia means matter offered in
explanation or defense apology usually
applies to an expression of regret for a
mistake or wrong with implied admission
of guilt or fault and with or without
reference to mitigating or extenuating
circumstances
apologia implies not admission of guilt
or regret but a desire to make clear the
grounds for some course belief or
position
the most famous apologia in history was
offered by socrates when he was
condemned to death
defending himself he turned the tables
on his accusers demonstrating very
precisely just why he was feared hated
and sentenced to die
a more famous missive has rarely if ever
been penned
and i would very much recommend its
reading it's very short to those
watching and listening i don't claim to
have reached socratic heights in my
defense but do hope that the public
discussion
will help shed some needed light on the
manner in which i might conduct myself
better in such matters in the future
and perhaps have some broader
educational and moral significance
in closing in relationship to this intro
i want to sincerely thank both jonathan
pajo and greg hurwitz for having the
courage to engage in this conversation
i hope
that their efforts are understood in the
spirit in which they were offered
on to the show
i'm sitting here today with greg hurwitz
and jonathan pago they're two colleagues
of mine and two friends and these things
are very
tricky and so the way you think them
through is to take a look at your own
behavior
and to
to rake yourself over the coals in the
most fundamental way and one of the
reasons i like to talk to greg is
because he's very very good at
making that kind of fine discrimination
and he's a very good advocate
for the side of the political spectrum
that i'm more alienated from because
they've been after me
for about six years and jonathan is just
eminently reasonable in these regards
and also quite deep and so greg and i
decided that he would
interrogate me that's one way of
thinking about it or help me interrogate
myself that's probably more accurate
about
how to draw lines in public about
contentious things without alienating
the people that you're trying to draw
lines in relationship to so badly that
it's no longer possible to communicate
with them
it's funny because i think one of the
issues is that i think even for you greg
is that everybody feels like you have a
role to play and i think a lot of this
is playing up against this role because
you are this
catalyst for transformation you have
been this catalyst to transformation and
everybody kind of sees that
and when they see you straying from that
role one way or another they're
wondering what's going on and i think
sometimes i think people forget that
you're a person that also slips and
slides and messes up and does especially
on twitter especially especially on
twitter but there is nonetheless a
reality about the fact that you do seem
to play some kind of role
and and and that if
so it's good to talk about it and i
think people are displaying right that's
right and that role should be flexible
and part of it for me is that the role
that you're playing has become too rigid
in certain ways
and it does that's a danger yeah and it
doesn't match my conception of you and
it doesn't match what i think is
strategically the best use of your
talent and insight yeah well and so we
want to wade into the platform issue too
because like if the issue is
serious enough to be worth considering
then maybe it's too serious to
say anything about on twitter one of the
things i should say about those tweets
just just to begin with is
i put out a lot of tweets and
some of them go absolutely nowhere thank
god and then some of them explode and it
is by no means obvious to me in the
least which of the things that i'm
saying are going to
go off like little bombs and so that's
also a very weird thing about twitter so
if you were
exposing yourself to a more robust range
of ideas it would be more obvious to you
is number one so it's predictably going
off in one way
first of all and second of all you and i
had the conversation maybe it might be
that the people who are responding to it
are more likely to all come from one
side
so but your point still will take it
well well you can hear but let's call it
dog whistles and by that i don't mean
the connotation that it is actually a
dog whistle for something that is racist
or fast right so it's like people
are such right you can tune your ear to
that all the way around the spectrum now
not perfectly but your ear
is not tuned to things that to language
that you're using and how it translates
and in some ways part of why i'm talking
to you is by dent of our relationship in
some ways i think i might be the best
point of contact for what everybody to
the left of you thinks
yeah right that's true and so i and
right now like everybody to the left of
you is does not have a high
view of where you are and what you're
doing and that's problematic because
we've spent a lot of time bridge
building and also that's not you you're
not a
sort of
rigid conservative and i don't mean all
conservatives are rigid i mean
but you're you're like a northern
alberta outlaw biker like that's a big
part of your personal yeah i mean and
you're like
there's whole aspects of you that are
liberal and it's the integration of the
two cards it's so shameful it is
changeful that's right but you can only
hide like
parts yeah that's right
yeah but so when it's the other thing
it's like it's not it's not making sense
but you're also not talking to half of
your people well so sometimes i've gone
to greg gone with greg to washington to
to talk to democrats and i've often
asked democrats that i've talked to who
i've talked to when the left goes too
far and they're usually unable to answer
and i've suggested that it's equity when
they go too far when they promote equity
and
greg has stepped in several times during
these conversations when i'm objecting
to equity to say
when you're talking about equity the
democrats you're talking to don't hear
the same thing because they just hear
equality of opportunity which by the way
equity is definitely not most democrat i
mean i'm not claiming that no yeah no no
no but that's happened that's happened
directly well the conversations have
been happening and so there is this need
for translation why don't we start with
one of the actual tweets we can start
with the
one that also predating this okay so
before these happened you and i had a
conversation where i said
you're tweeting in my estimation too
erratically and too impulsively and
saying if you have something important
to say about something like say maybe
islam or like race in america right it
requires a little bit more like if
you're going to pick on these like small
topics with no complexity you should
take more time and do it as an op-ed
right and when you've talked about it i
said to you because you said look i've
been thinking about it forever and i
said how long did you think about these
three tweets and your answer was about a
second you know that's twitter right
there's a place to think and so that's
another issue is one of the things that
happened when i got kicked off twitter
i could have been outraged by it
although i really wasn't um i actually
found it bemusing i suppose especially
given the timing because it happened
exactly the same day that i joined the
daily wire which was ridiculously
comical in some fundamental sense but my
biggest reaction
in some sense and of course this also
raises the question of motive is that i
was mostly relieved it's like i've been
trying in some ways to wash my hands of
twitter for three years and then i kept
getting
sucked back in
and
and i'm not trying to make excuses for
that by the way i'm trying to figure it
out
my family has asked me to stop using
twitter sometimes or said that it might
not be good and i i was torn
for three reasons is that i use twitter
to follow a lot of the people that i've
that i know like 500 people kind of see
what they're up to i used it at least to
some degree as a topical news source but
more importantly and more fundamentally
i believe that
because i have a large social media
presence and i'm very interested in
communication i wanted to learn how all
the social media networks worked and you
actually cannot learn how they work and
so what's wrong with them or how to use
them properly without using them and to
use them you have to subject yourself to
the errors that go along with them and
so as a diagnostician because i've
talked to jonathan hayden to
and to stephen pinker about the
pathologies of social media networks and
i can't figure out how they're
pathological unless i use them and the
problem with that is that if they're
pathological and you use them then you
get sucked into the pathology and so i
couldn't just because lots of people
wrote me about the tweets and said well
i never use twitter and i don't know why
this is a problem and if you were a good
person you just would ignore it
completely it's like yeah
fair enough like that's that's a
possibility but it's certainly not
obvious i think anyone on twitter who
has a phone is addicted me included and
i have to you said twitter really did
you in during during the last election
cycle i can't be on it in any way and i
don't think you know who what you're
doing when you're on there you're
talking to troll farms from st
petersburg and you're talking to
algorithms and ai you're talking to
troll like you don't even know what
you're doing well you're also talking
when you're engaging with the people you
think you're following they don't
they're not fully in control of why
they're in there and so it's like this
video game that you're playing and in
the video game
then you're impetuously engaging in ways
that can be insulting without having the
humility to come out of it and go oh wow
i was off on my corner of the internet
and i said this thing in a game
circumstance that had
that that had a real world declaration
the context of which didn't make sense
to me but means something else let's
talk about it doesn't mean you're wrong
it also well there's another element of
twitter too that's peculiar in in a very
deep and horrible way is that first of
all i don't remember how many million
followers have but lots and so there are
people many
millions of people who are in the
potential database of recipients of my
messages but like
one in a thousand of them is having the
worst day that
one in a thousand people
is having and that might be the person
who's responding with a comment if
they're not a troll from saint peter's
how many did elon say or trolls well who
knows right that's probably why he
didn't so you're between they're playing
a game where you're being manipulated
constantly by ai and then and then it's
the tail that wags the dog because
twitter on its own if you look at the
skew of how many people post the
percentage of americans who post the
percentage then of americans were
let's just talk america because this is
what some of this is engaging right now
yeah but then the percentage of them who
post the most often and then what's fake
and influence like you don't even know
what you're engaging with no no
well that's that's a huge problem
because it's a biased sample that looks
like a community that's right and it's
biased in ways you don't understand and
then it's even worse because it's biased
towards the narcissists and the
psychopaths and the machiavellians and
the trolls and the ai farms and then
it's even worse than that because it's
biased to promote the worst of their
utterances as fast as possible and so
and you don't need help with that like
you've spent six years tied to a cactus
with the worst elements of the left
kicking you in the face for six years
like you don't need more exposure to the
worst of anonymous
controlled people
as generally i can see what it does in
the back of my mind like and this is
part of the reason that i'm worried
about the situation that we're in right
now is that i can see
the desire for mayhem emerging within me
as a consequence of being
exposed to this kind of
narcissistic caustic element that just
runs riot on twitter and what happens in
part with your responses to my mind is
it starts to be dehumanizing about the
other side not in a soft liberally sense
but meaning you start to talk about the
the left as a monolith and it's like
it's not a monolith any more than when
you say and we should start with justice
jackson yeah because she had one answer
that you didn't like and fair enough
right yeah so well we could go through
that so so i don't remember exactly the
specifics of the tweet but i can set up
the context so when the biden
correct me if i'm wrong when the biden
administration moved forward with the
supreme court justice nomination the way
they did it strategically and we had
been you and i have been working with
the democrats for a long time at this
point the way they did it strategically
was something like it's time for uh
a woman and a black woman on the supreme
court and i thought jesus you guys you
already hung her out to dry because the
right way to do that even if that was
your goal was to say
it's time for a really qualified proper
candidate on the supreme court and then
to move forward with the search and then
say well look we found this person and
isn't it lovely that she has these great
qualifications and also has these other
elements of significance and then she
set up for success and so i thought that
was just dismal and ridiculous and
i think the way i reacted to it in the
tweet i also think about this
statistically because if you
eliminate men from consideration then
you've reduced the pool of of applicants
who are qualified by 50 and then if you
reduce it by ethnicity well in this case
to the black population you reduce that
50 by another 87
and so now you're down to 5
of qualified candidates and the
probability that you're going to find
the most qualified candidate in that
pool is it's 5
you could but it's very unlikely and so
i also found that
given that the importance of the
position i also found that annoying
when i pointed it out that this the
candidate pool had been restricted to
you you said well you don't understand
that in the previous nominations there
were all sorts of restrictions that were
equally as intense for equally pleasing
that's so let's talk that through just
for a second before we get to the issue
of the woman well i said to you you're
not an expert in race in america and
it's evident from the way you're talking
about it and you should approach it with
more humility especially as pertains to
blacks in america and i also said you're
not an expert in the supreme court like
by a long time and you said but i'm an
expert at selection criteria that was
your answer and i said fine so instead
of angry
like tweet warrior jordan you can do an
assessment of what has pissed you off
about the selection process but then it
was also the strategic issue because i
was also annoyed i thought well jesus
guys even by the lights of your own moon
let's say you screwed up here because it
was strategically foolish you you hung
your candidate out to dry right at the
beginning and that was part of the
irritation why did you not speak up when
the last three candidates going through
are on a short list from
multiple conservative
think tanks and operations like
everybody knows the short short list
that's being considered by trump that's
cut the field immensely but one short
list is ideological political and what
is your opinion based on my politics the
other is literally just gender and race
race okay so i would argue in some
regards so let's go to that then it's
gender and race reagan said he wanted
intersectionality he wanted to say that
sandra day o'connor he said he needs to
appoint a woman so nobody's like home
sobbing about that
right so for a balance of the court
i don't think that he should have done
it i don't like that biden did it i
think he should have done it the way you
did it and i was
i was outraged
strategically and i was frustrated
morally so you have a list of people who
have a certain ideological orientation
and you're saying that's fine to my mind
you're saying it's fine
do you think it's different worse
i think intersectionality is worse i
think that to jordan's point i think
it's worse because it undermines the
person themselves it's saying
you know one is saying okay you're there
because you have a certain political
opinion and the other is saying you're
there because you look a certain way
it's not saying you have a certain
political opinion it's saying you're on
a short list of approved people in a
certain way that's acceptable to people
in power who have been negotiating this
i have a real hard time with the notion
that that short list should be composed
in any way of of of characteristics like
gender and race okay so let me just
understand why okay so so
reagan did it too and all the first
supreme court justices did it they were
all white and there were black people
who were here and so it's not that it's
not yeah but
it doesn't justify it but what i'm
saying is that everything's complicated
yeah and so if you're an expert on
selection which you are
then no problem do this selection and
lambast it but do everybody else also
and put her in a tradition of supreme
court justices who have been chosen due
to different cultural and political ties
and the reason for it is is in the
selection of her rather than who we got
who were
three justices who who prevaricated it
best under oath about
roe v wade and when i say prevaricate i
mean they fooled republican senators
unless that's kabuki theater and susan
collins like they were very careful and
cautious around it or they chose
somebody who happens to be black and a
woman they set it up front i don't like
that who is a spectacular
candidate look she is for me this has
almost nothing to do in this situation
with with her merits as a candidate
because it's possible and perhaps even
likely that she's a highly credible
candidate but but it's also because i
was willing once we had this discussion
i thought well i can give you that i can
give you that all right so fine the
previous candidates were also selected
from an inappropriately restricted short
list jonathan's point is relevant
because well that was part of the
adversarial political process and maybe
still within the game we'll leave that
aside for now but i was thinking okay
i'll oh i'll give you that i'll give you
that i'll give you
that she was she was qualified and that
previous nominees were subject to an
equally biased selection mechanism when
she was subject to that question what is
a woman
i thought
that just that's question sucks i know
it was a gotcha question and she could
have said
and i'm not also expecting her to be
perfect under those circumstances right
because that's a lot to ask she could
have said
don't ask me that question that's an
annoying question you're just trying to
hem me in here and it's inappropriate
under the circumstances and i would have
thought no problem
i'm not a biologist
first of all that's a really bad answer
it's first of all because it admits that
the fundamental issue here is biological
and it isn't obvious to me that the
people who are on the left who are
interested in gender fluidity etc want
that answer but it's also it also
annoyed me because it's like well wait a
second here
we were supposed to be celebrating
because you're a woman now also because
you're black but certainly because
you're a woman
and now
we're being asked to not agree that
there's such a thing as a woman it's
like and then i thought well that not
only was that annoying for all the
reasons i already laid out but it was
annoying because i thought well now i
have to
i have to sacrifice the principle of
non-contradiction i have to i'm being
called upon to accept two opposing
things simultaneously that are not
commensurate and i'm just not willing to
do that
and it's a bad answer in very very many
ways and i i do feel bad for her because
i know what it's like to be put on the
spot in an interview with questions like
that but i'm not a biologist it's like
jesus it's a teacher really yeah no it's
a terrible answer i'm not going to
defend something that i don't agree with
but what i will say and i thought it was
a terrible answer and there's also a way
to answer it as a liberal that's way
more reasonable to say of course here's
generally how we define it you could
also say i'm not answering it because
it's a game but you could also say
here's generally how we think of it but
there's kleinfelders and there's
variation and there's different stuff
and gender and biology you can you can
say something that's fluid and still
not fluid that way but flexible
and still holding into common sense
values that the majority of americans
can understand there's a bigger part of
this and part of it is is you're drilled
down
on your expertise which is selection
process but you're not drilling down on
that generally about the whole supreme
court and in history just on her and
additionally you're missing the bigger
picture
and the bigger picture is this this is a
woman who by conservative standards by
the con by the standards that we all
care about meritocracy
toughness she's a woman of god she's
been married 25 years she's got kids she
was a she was the head of the harvard
law review she has more qualifications
than her conceivable that i can even
remember and she's then they shouldn't
have hung her out to dry to begin with
that's right you know what but same with
kavanaugh jesus is
you're contributing to the demeaning
instead of saying wow here's this thing
and wow she had a bad moment you said
and you and i knew what happened um
you were often some i know exactly what
happened because you sent me all your
emails and there was some idiotic like
equity
proposal in physics grants that was
happening in oh god like that like
justin trudeau personally
it was some awful thing in your morning
and you wrote a tweet about her that
said
yay d-e-i well i guess she looks the
part and what i said and i knew where
you were
and i know you're not racist i'm no more
racist than the next northern albertan
that's right that's right but there's i
think so i just want to i just want to
interject a little bit because
i think that there's a bigger picture
that i think jordan's coming from at
least for sure that i'm coming from
which is i'm definitely more on the
right side and one of the things i've
noticed
is that for example this
people get away with calling other
people racist nonstop all the time in
the media on twitter on youtube you can
call someone racist that's right and
there are there's absolutely no
consequence there's no discussion
there's no conversation and so now i
just want to point out that this
conversation
is quite particular because
jordan
gives out a few tweets that are a little
off color that are maybe too partisan or
whatever and then everything explodes
and the left is like well he's the nazi
we thought he's the nazi we thought all
right thank you god they're thankful
that you made those tweets because
they're fi everything is consolidating
their image yeah that you're a racist
but i but i need i think it's important
to say that that was that's also part of
the discussion and part of the
discussion is
i know i know you're not racist i know
that and what i said to you was if i
didn't know you and i read that tweet
and i'm not a big call everybody racist
i don't know that i'm not racist i what
i do know is that i'm trying very hard
not to be and so here's what i mean
sorry you're right yeah i mean you're
not racist in the knee-jerk way that it
gets applied i don't think it's a virtue
right but i mean you're not racist the
way that people quickly dismiss you as
racist yeah everybody has to look at
ways in which we have biases and where
that has to do with it i would say in
canada that for me that's probably be
more acute on the
native american native canadian first
nations people caucasian front because
where i grew up the fundamental racial
divide was not black versus white that's
not the canadian divide the canadian
divide is either french versus english
or it's native versus
versus european and so when i go to
reservations let's say when i interact
with the natives who i've been coming to
know more over the last years
i carry with me the
freighted
perceptual lens of my upbringing and
and i'm always on the lookout to see how
that might be affecting me yes and so
and that's exactly i don't presume that
i'm not racist that's right some sense
because
well fair i mean i mean the foolish
racist i mean
what i'll say is you don't have that and
you don't understand it with race in
america and yet you blithely
trotted in and you did so in a way that
was denigrating that if i didn't know
you i would think was a racial slur and
i'm not somebody who's inclined to think
that about people like let's say that
there's a liberal who's kind of
interesting who dresses
what is it tweed punk right like a tweed
punk leprechaun interesting ideas
flashes of brilliance like you're sort
of looking at him going sometimes long
periods of brilliance that's true it's
true flashes mostly but occasionally a
sustained burst and so
and you're interested but you don't
agree and the next move that person does
is come up to canada and make a totally
tone-deaf slight against the residential
schools in a knowing way
i would say you coming into america
with your lack of knowledge and inter
and expressed interest in race in
america and choosing to make a comment
by tweet about race in america which is
illegal it is missing anything that
sounds like dog whistles to reasonable
people including me if i didn't know you
to go that's a slur and she's deserving
of your respect
fair enough jonathan do you have
anything to close that off with
no i think
i mean
i think that
the feeling i get right now i don't know
greg i feel like we're really falling
into a lot of detail and into a lot of
weeds in terms of the
this particular thing i think
my my perception is that there's a
bigger issue like there's a bigger issue
which is
the manner in which
for you as someone who's definitely more
on the left
and your relationship with jordan and
how in this in his public kind of coming
out
you have felt like until then
he was able to
speak both sides and to speak reasonably
to both sides and although you may i
think jordan's probably more
conservative than you are but you felt
like he's honest he he he he takes it
seriously
and like the channel for interview for
me was it's like that image of him
actually undermining
the way people perceive him and and
laughing and being charming and being
flexible and actually kind of bringing
which is hard to do on twitter that's
right and that's right and there's
something i think the the major
perception you have is that with these
tweets and some of the messaging that
has been happening recently you feel
like you don't have access to that
jordan anymore or you can defend jordan
to your side in the way that you used to
be able that's right that's beautiful i
think it's just important to kind of
keep it into that and that's exactly
right and the dream is a lot about that
because part of it for me is you're not
supposed to be that you're not supposed
to be speaking in wooden language you're
not supposed to be speaking let's go to
the dream then here so this is a strange
thing to do in the middle of this
conversation but
it makes sense like one of the things i
did learn as a clinician and certainly
in my own marriage and in my own life
that often if you were fortunate during
a time of
query and crisis let's say indeterminacy
now and then you can get a dream and if
you're lucky the dream will reveal
things to you that are part of the
answer to that problem and that's not
that surprising because dream is a form
of thought and the dream thought is
trying to solve problems and so it just
turned out that when greg came here
he had a dream which is very comical
dream
and so jonathan and i and greg sat down
and talked about this dream a bit and we
thought we might discuss it in this
in this forum
one of the things i learned from jung
and i believe that this is true is that
dreams are the voice of nature in the
deepest sense and they don't lie now you
may not be able to figure out what they
mean because the dream is trying to
figure out what things mean and so you
have to
translate the dream just like you have
to translate the work of literature but
the dream at least has that
sense of objective truth in the deepest
sense
and
and and you can really rely on it so do
you want to lay out the dream a bit and
then jonathan you had some really good
this is so funny it's like
it's like for a liberal have your dream
analyzed by jordan peterson on the world
wide web for the daily wire it's like
what could be a worse idea it's like
yeah how could this go wrong this should
be just fantastic and not at all like
self-adoring at the same time yeah yeah
this is the setup then we're going to
talk about my dream world because you're
not in enough trouble already so ah okay
so i woke up in the dream
having left a place that was an idyllic
bucolic
new englandy college right in the
countryside green hilly slopes
and i already i already left there but i
lived there in the dorm room it's a
dream humanist tradition in some reality
that's right that's right
um and you're comfortable there and like
i love it because i love it
and what's interesting is
i think of that as liberal because
liberal arts education which is the most
like it's the and i thought of hillsdale
right but it's also conservative because
it's little c and little l and that's
what they look like yeah it's the actual
union of the two traditions in the
highest sense that
yeah it's a cloister where you can
explore ideas and so part of this is is
it's like so the best of
of conservativism and the best of
liberalism when they live together in
that way that's the human performance
yeah
so so that's why i worked right and so
i'm in a forest and it's a
it's dark and nightmarish and it's stark
and it's like dead branches that cast
long shadows and i'm walking through it
well that's a great image because the
dead branch is the dead wood that should
burn off and it's casting a long shadow
so that ties into the whole shadow issue
and it is dead branches that cast the
longest shadows and grip at you when
you're walking through the forest and so
that's a great image that's right
and so
i'd love to take credit for it she's a
writer i'm like yeah it's wonderful but
it has nothing to do with me um
but so then i arrive at this place and
it's so interesting and it's like so
this is all offensive but we're gonna
just we're gonna talk it through so
you're there and you're like hillbilly
you you're more hillbilly you than you
are i should say it's a different
gradation of hillbilly
and you're still dressed in your like
you know like
boston celtics leprechaun outfit but
it's like i don't really like it when
you reduce northern albertan hill
buildings to american hillbillies i
think that's kind of the meaning we're
our own
that was his experience that's the dream
yeah by the way hillbillies are great
too so it's like it's denigrating but
like i want to make sure like no kill
billies should be harmed in the making
of this dream because like
i'll hang out with hillbillies all day
so anyways but it's like bad and it's
degenerate and and you had a great point
on this and you're there and everyone
you're in like over like overalls suit
it's like tweet overalls
it's so funny
it was so funny and everyone's all
around and it's very like participatory
and and everyone's kind of partying
around
and i was and i got there i said there
was a deliverance element too totally
yeah people are like just sex yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah the whole hillbilly
catastrophe happening there's a glitch
there is a hillbill there's a jordan
peterson like hillbilly
yeah it's going on it's like a festival
but people are playing stuff like a
cello made out of like forks and strings
and like everything's homemade and it
was sad and as you said it's like well
that's harder to make than you think
like you could try and make a cello out
of a fork and strings but it's a mess
and you're walking around and you're
your inquisitive self like where your
hands are behind your back and your
brows furrowed and you're like you're
paying attention well when you're paying
attention well but it was performative
and i was mad at you when i was there
and then you said something that i don't
remember but it was denigrating to me in
a way that
it was
i wish i could remember but you
basically said something that was like
trying to
call forth and mean imposter syndrome
that i'm acting in ways that i don't
belong and i should be embarrassed and
then i'm embarrassing myself and i
should watch it so it's an accusation of
something like hypocrisy something like
that imposterism i'm not i'm not as good
or where i think that i am yeah and i
was really mad at you and i was mad at
you on two fronts actually i was dream
mad at him the whole next day at the
seminar like
when you're apart like yeah he showed up
i'm like you were
you're like yeah i was i was dream mad
at him like the whole day it still
hasn't fully worn off because you were
horrible but so i was mad at you for two
things one of them is when i got there i
was like yay
jordan's here this is gonna be fun
there's gonna be an adventure and that's
the first rule of our friendship always
we always have fun and we always laugh
unless things are really shitty and then
we can at least make fun of it in an
irreverent way that makes it somewhat
tolerable like if there's a health thing
or like we've been through plenty on
both sides that have been awful yeah but
we're still funny
and it still is i'm i'm funny with you
but we're still funny
yes that's true
um have funnier looking
okay
greg is sadly funnier than you did i i
i i
know what to say you're all like locked
in
yeah don't take as many swings it's sad
but so you're not it wasn't like you
should be safe
that's not how that's not my
relationship with you you're not like a
safe
you're not a safe space for me right in
any way but your fun and your adventure
and you always always have my best
intentions in mind
even when we're fighting and even when
we're arguing and you didn't and i was
like that's not you and i knew it right
away and by the way so that's also what
you're worried about at the deep level
yeah and and the daily wire thing also
brings that up because people have been
wondering you know what's going to
happen
is this is this
is this a tilt into something outside of
the domain that we've been talking about
and there's a moral hazard associated
with what's happening
it's like let me insult like a
transcendently
competent black supreme court justice
like a 25 year old
like big boned woman and
like a trans person and then quit
twitter and join the daily wire it's
like okay good jordan this will be this
will make the bridge building aspects of
my life easier and to explain why you're
not like a captured entity and let me
also do it in
unthoughtful captured language right
that has worked its way through a
particular ecosystem
and by the way daily wire i don't have
that bias like i'm you know i've met ben
but they're also concerned about that on
the daily wire front i mean part of the
reason that
forces is because they want to escape
from the narrow partisans this is a
conversation we could have in good faith
with ben and andrew clavin like we could
they could be here this isn't us talking
behind their back yeah they're obviously
not behind their back wow yeah
yeah since they're all here yeah right
tearing down i forgot about it
now
that's right yeah yeah well that's this
is okay we're back to the dream okay so
back to the dream so i was really mad at
you yeah and i knew in real it was an
embodied dream because in real time
i knew that it was also about this and
that's really weird and so i was
embodied in that which was cool so i was
like okay this is now and i knew i'm
coming to have this conversation and i
don't want to have this conversation
really
i do want i i need to have the
conversation but i don't necessarily
want to yeah because it's i prefer i
prefer talking to you privately yeah i
think that there might be more good that
comes from this yeah
it exposes me to a lot which i'm not
fearful of but i want to make sure that
it's worth it
right and i also i'm not i'm not
i'm not certain that this isn't
performative in the same way that i'm
critical of you
after the when you got kicked off
twitter and everything turned into like
the kardashians of twitter
who have
you know big prefrontal cortexes like i
don't like that whole game
but so part of what happened was i was
so i knew that the dream was this same
thing and i also knew when you came at
me for the imposter syndrome that it hit
me and it hurt the way that insult hurts
like it shuddered me like in boxing when
you take a full blow but then it wasn't
real like it couldn't touch me i felt it
in full and then i went ah you're wrong
you're not you i don't have that
in this i might have it and plenty of
other things plenty of other ways i
might be a fool
or or be as of yet undeceived about the
ways that i think i know more than i do
yeah but it's not this and that's why
you didn't have my best interests in
mind
if you've done that you've done that
plenty on things that i don't
know and fine yeah right like let's get
it out let's move yeah but that was that
was the fear in the dream is that
i'm criticizing you and not acting in in
good faith that's right so we're in
amongst the hillbillies partying away
and you're you're doing you're your
focused attentive self but as i'm
watching you
i'm realizing one that it's performative
because i'm looking at it being because
i i look where you look often right and
to some extent vice versa if something's
like really of interest to you and
you're focused okay so i got something
popped into my mind about that you know
when i was a kid
i hung around with the more delinquent
guys not that there was any shortage of
them in fairview and there was a reason
for that
i mean first of all i was intellectual
and i was small and because i was
younger in my class i also had a harder
time on the athletic front and so there
was a bit of compensation in that i
would say to hang around with the tough
kids the tough misbehaving kids and i
could do that i mean
it it had its costs but i could do that
and the old there weren't a lot of
alternatives as well it's a very small
town and so there might be a part of me
too that has a proclivity
to want to appeal more
to that
rough and tumble
working class rough edge of the world
which i also think is is a plus i mean i
think you have that to somebody you do
and one of the things we've been talking
about is like is the fact that i swear
too much i'm a crime novel right and in
certain circumstances i'm it's very much
part of my parlance and i don't think
it's
i don't think it's as usefully updated
when appropriate i think that's right
well i also think that it's been good
for you
in many many senses to also have had
some appeal to the military types and
the police department because that
doesn't help with the swearing part no
no
fair enough i've just learned all the
best stuff but no no but so you can
easily you can easily pan you can eat
there can easily be a part of that
that's a pandering and an inappropriate
pandering and oh yeah yeah and i don't
so there was a formative element yeah
the dream is putting me forward as as
inappropriately performative
in relationship to
the dream
is characters like like fork cello and
so i'm looking at it and then i have
this realization where i'm like jordan
like the hillbilly incest fork cello
it's just not that fascinating and like
what am i doing here we should be paying
attention to something else and i
usually pay attention what you pay
attention to because it illuminates
meaning or discussion point or a
fruitful disagreement and i just
realized that this is there's no life
here this is kind of dead
well that's not that's that incest
ancestors motif you know so one of the
things jung talked about
he has a whole symbolic chapter on this
about the place where only like mates
with light well jonathan
yeah so i think one of the things that i
that i've been thinking about is to
understand let's see if we think about
right left as a basic category the way
that you talk about it which is
conservative and then more liberal and
more open
the the conservative
they tend to d the way that we
dehumanize we could say or the monster
that we perceive the conservative tends
to
have a something like a chimera monster
things that don't go together the idea
of something which is strange which is
unrecognizable something which is fluid
and mixed and a mixture of cats that's
what they see as they that's what they
see as the monster that's what they
project as a monster and interestingly
enough let's say the the from the left
side the monster is the opposite it's
something that's too close and the
hillbilly has become mythologically in
american culture the image and so
deliverance is like a left wing fantasy
right right right right right right
right right right right right right so
left holes have eyes it's a horror movie
so so you have this idea of first of all
you have the idea of something that's
too local something that is incestuous
and therefore is too close
you know and and is too their identity
is so local that it almost becomes
idiosyncratic because it's so local and
so and so it becomes sterile and
deformed as a consequence exactly in
real time in the dream and that's what i
mean that it was in body dream i thought
that's how i think when i'm seeing the
tweets which is not that it's a moral
judgment on you but you've now
surrounded yourself in a hall of
likeness then you're oblivious to how
you're engaging with the world and the
manner in which you're doing so and
you're helpless against even the own
self-con pledges of self-control that
you made to yourself in your engagement
with the world while you're
simultaneously lecturing about ethics
and christ around the world and i
thought that's that's wrong
it's and when i try sub-optimal at least
sub-optimal
yes yeah well well right because there's
a lot you do right all the time mm-hmm
and it's like we
i don't like complimenting you in in
what you have been through in certain
ways in facing the absolute
worst elements of the far left and by
that i don't mean liberals and i don't
mean democrats and i don't mean
moderates has been
harrowingly horrible it's been it's like
if it's being
it's a horror movie as written by kafka
it's been awful and a large part of why
i've been able to be undeceived about
the problems that are happening on my
side is in large part because of the
closeness of my relationship with you
because i saw it in ways that were
undeniable and you and i are too close
for me to dismiss you
if you say something that i believe is
dumb if you say something that
is misinterpreted if you say something
in a way that doesn't make sense and we
might have to argue about for two weeks
to see where it comes down to i i can't
i can't dismiss you for it and so part
of it is i took that right early you're
like oh you're almost like the original
cancel
culture icon lucky you
right it's been it's been a pleasure but
you've been battered and you've dealt
with a lot of it way better than anybody
thinks or knows in the mainstream media
and on the left now that said you also
asked for a lot because by dint of the
fact that you're an ascendant character
who has a religious aspect to some
people has a moral aspect and has a
professorial
and professional aspect
and so it's important to say that while
we're talking about this this isn't like
me coming in and beating you like a
pinata that you need to be perfect but
it's saying with everything that you are
and with the capacity that you have to
speak in a transcendent way to more
people you have a moral responsibility
to take more care with your words so
that you're not thoughtlessly
denigrating whole swaths of people who
need to
at least hear from you or hear a
perspective that you have to offer
that's immensely helpful the same way
that i say with a lot of moderate
democrats who i think are incredible
moral people well the failure to wrangle
a proper messaging apparatus is it can
be a moral failure also so one of the
problems that i have
is
trying while trying to establish a
balanced view i have a two-dimensional
problem i would say is first of all
as an academic the people who
are troublesome
on the professional front to me are not
the radical right because
the radical left is destroying the
educational system and the radical right
isn't there at all
so that puts me in a particularly weird
position professionally and it's a
unidimensional position but then i would
also say that the people who have come
after me most effectively and most
continuously although there's been some
of that on the right that's never really
been very effective um
it's all been from the left and right
and so i know as well that it's
a moral hazard in that in that it's not
as easy for me to be balanced in my view
and then or there's one other dimension
to that too is that
i don't see the radical left as penitent
in any real sense and this actually
extends out into the liberal community
more broadly because in many ways the
entire world has decided the nazis were
that was just
not
acceptable but we have not decided that
about the communists and so we still
have places in the united states where
there's statues to lend and then people
still wear
che guevara shirts and trumpet their
alliance with the even the communist
ideals not working class labor socialism
and so there's a lack of penitence on
the left that really
that really disturbs me and so i have
the nexus of those three things that's
the left's issue with the confederate
flag
i'm not advocating this so i don't want
to say that these things are the same
they're not the same but there's a lot
of ways that the
symbols move both ways but it is not the
ascendant
200 years ago on the other hand it's
like the 100 million people that were
dead because of communism not even 40
years or years ago but but it's
america's original sin but there's
there's definitely i mean the trucker
protest was a great example where there
was one confederate flag at the trucker
protest yeah yeah yeah the media talked
about it for months
communist flag
every single one yeah and no one noticed
yeah no one says anything let's look
here's the hammer and the same part of
it is like canada is different and
that's also one of the things we talk
about all the time is it's like canada
has different ascendant forces that are
problematic and i'm not comparing it and
i that was what made it even worse in
canada it's like well even it was a
confederate flag that's actually not a
canadian issue so not in any fundamental
sense and so and i don't see any signs
well but it on the left penitence jesus
it took the social psychologist 70 years
to admit that there was such a thing as
left-wing totalitarianism i know and
still it's a it's a narrow part of the
field like oops well maybe it's there
too yeah you think really you think and
and it's part it's part and parcel of
the problem of the left
and it's in the universities they won't
draw boundaries and it's where
yes but in different ways the right
won't either
yeah but they drew a boundary between
them and the nazis
and the left has not driven drawn a
boundary between them and the communists
and i know it's harder too i understand
that it's harder
it because i think it is i do think it
is i think it's harder because the thing
about the communists is that they
promised
universal benevolence
and then and the nazis never did no they
said no this is for the aries right and
so there's a transcendent promise in
communism that's not that's not
conservative conservatives come in the
big in the front door we talked about
this last night like the the
conservative gone wrong when they're of
the right is a big guy with a club who
comes in and smashes stuff and it's like
it's definable you know what it is
liberals when it goes wrong is like a
swarm of paper cutting mosquitoes that
like shred you to death and those are
the two variants and if you're one one
kind of makes sense and if you're of a
mob of paper cut shredding mosquitoes
that's they think that's their only
chance and justification to go up
against the other one and of course we
don't want either of those things and so
of course it devolved that way but it
doesn't matter that if they're promising
universal benevolence if that's not
what's happening it doesn't matter it
doesn't make it harder we also have to
understand too that whatever is
bedeviling our country our our
civilization if we reduce it to the
partisan then we let it win because this
network of ideas that's tearing us apart
has its it has its tendrils up
everywhere and if we can say well it's
only on the left then well then it wins
it because it can hide in that and if we
say it's only on the right it wins as
well and when you are off what i think
of as your calling
you're not being
transformative and what you're being is
all of a sudden you're like feeding
these kind of
red
right walking talking points moving out
in language that doesn't sound like you
and denigrating the opposition in a way
that is that i think is bully-like it
makes you seem mean and small and petty
and bully-like and also
that's the problem with going after a
single individual
because there's all these have different
things that i had very different
reactions to all three of them but also
what it does is that
it eliminates your ability to
differentiate the other side and so when
you start ranting about the most
convenient
the marxist social like it's a rant and
it's not you it's like it's captured
language when you're and it's like okay
sure i can do an equal rant about the
worst aspect of the furthest right and
how they're racist doesn't have any
bearing on the conservatives in my
community my friends who were in the
military my friends who were born again
christians i mean i can keep ranting a
whole list of the worst of the right but
it's making them a monolith and you pull
the individual into a monolithic thing
and you don't differentiate them and you
don't want people doing that with you
and we don't want people doing that with
you because we need you to discern them
because yeah okay so you're called out
you're called out in the dream by my
hillbilly self for your moral failings
but you don't take that personally and
then i feel it and then i go oh you
dismiss it so i'm not taking you
personally and then that's really sad
for me okay so then there's the next
part of the dream the next part of the
dream is you're going off with your
licentious hillbilly orgy and people are
like pairing off and going to rooms and
i get offered like a hillbilly woman and
i had it was amazing
so and i had this moment like a first
reaction where i'm like i'm married i
don't cheat on my wife i'm not going to
go to a back room with a hillbilly but
then i had did have a second thought
where i was like also the hillbilly
women are not very attractive so i'm
like i was slightly relieved and
slightly terrifying so like it wasn't as
just surely an active virtue as possible
but nonetheless i was like no it was
clear morally and it also was clear that
it was it was other in a way that was
scary would be the non-funny part to say
it like i don't want to tingle in so you
weren't going to mate with what was
incestuous that's right yeah and there
was nothing that kind of motif of
creative union
so so that you were offered the
temptation of creative union with what
was too close and incestuous bond and
yes and you
said no yes right that's two parts
that's in line as i'm here in this
amazing company that i've been in for
the last week like that's interesting
right well because you were concerned
about coming down here because well this
is part
and parcel at least in some sense of the
daily wire operation going you also i
think you forgot to mention that the
dream in the dream the place where you
were getting there
so that that's okay but yeah i'm i'm
glad you're on that so then i'm in a
house
that is it's a bear house and the
closest thing that it could remind me of
was you know i went to albania at one
point and there's these mansions that
were built by like russian oligarchs to
escape and then they ran out of money
and they're these big platform concrete
like shells of
mansions
but they're never they're never given
life
and it's very it's got that eastern
european like graveyard of something
that would be grand from yeah like the
you know the ruins of the tower of babel
well and also like they're weirdly
bureaucrat they're trying to be majestic
but they also could be like the central
bureaucrat for ducting right like they
have this weird like
anyways and so it's a house like that
and it's on till and it's concrete and
there's water that's flooding up the
bottom of the house
and everyone's going off to have sex in
the various rooms that are also cabins
on a ship and the ship so that's also
extremely relevant right because that's
a that's an image of a decade
civilization is the house is collapsing
the waters are rising and in response
everyone's going off to their own rooms
to have sex with incestuous partners and
that's the polarization right so it's a
great image and another issue we call
that monday night yeah
i'm just kidding
yes exactly and then
and then i'm also aware that it's an
it's a grounded ark because it's on tilt
like when a boat comes up yeah i always
think about like the image when
um beowulf's boat comes back right and
it's the big it comes in crooked and so
i'm aware of that
so then there's it's a bit of a bomb
okay so it's on a tilt because uh-huh
it's on a tilt because it's crooked so
the house is crooked the house is
falling the house is filling it's an arc
it's like this arc ain't going to rise
right right we need arcs to rise
generally when there's a flood this
one's not rising because all you people
are off having hillbilly sacks hey i'm
not in the dream wait a minute
has joe's getting pulled in by the way
this is the next icon carving that we
need it's like yeah yeah it'll be like
your hieronymous bosch painting will be
like the hillbilly uh arc orgy
out in the margin yeah yeah yeah okay
okay so then basically then that's the
state of our civilization yeah it's
dismal it's dizzy
then you come after me and you're
yelling after me
it's more deprecations
and it's basically like you should doubt
yourself like you don't belong so you're
kind of standing in for the left in that
sense and in the twitter persona that
i've
been
adopting let's say at least in those
tweets and others as well and at first i
had like i said it's important i had a
moment of like oh like i don't like
taking a criticism we take criticisms
from
each other they're always with a
baseline of respect and admiration and
usually the harsher they are the more it
comes from there first of all but so i
took it like that first and then i was
like this is wrong and i'm leaving and
you're wrong and this whole scene's
wrong i was confident in that but you
weren't and that was weird because i was
leaving and generally we don't that's
not a place we wind up
so then i went away and outside it was
sort of an idyllic setting and then
tammy was there
and
tammy said to me and tammy and i it's
kind of interesting because tammy and i
are emily's my wife for those of you
listening who might not know that and
and greg and tammy know each other very
well and have for decades and
um
tammy has been in the conversations in
many times when we've been mutually
working out familial problems of
different intensity and personal
problems and all of that so and i don't
know exactly what image tammy plays
for you i know that
when you were first thinking about
getting married to delena tammy
definitely pushed on you and said
and if i remember correctly and said
this is like get out of there her and
tammy tammy waits and she's all quiet
and you're like oh what a meek
submissive kind woman then she just like
lops your legs off with the machete
that's like completely deserved
and she had some great calm so she's a
good feminine judge well she's also
embodied she's the embodied feminine in
that
you said that a while ago you said
tammy's so feminine right it took me a
long time because my wife is too and
that had very different meaning than how
i was raised but she's powerful from her
femininity in full mm-hmm and so when
she says stuff but tammy and i also have
of a affectionate and fun and joking
relationship it's not like it's always
serious but when tammy likes you yeah
which is
um
but if she pokes you it's worth paying
attention to
and she
look she's put up with him for how long
right so there's 50 years yeah is it
really 50. yeah i've known her since she
was oh that's right about 30 years so
anyway so and tammy's had tammy had me
and one of her tammy and i are like
dream allies sometimes in a way that's
kind of weird
and so tammy was there and she said to
me
um
don't worry
she said in our next book it was another
12 rules for life book we're writing and
devoting a chapter to you
i was like that's really weird right
because
you know
the hillbilly jordan who just like was
hurling you know
nod corn cobs at me up my way out of the
crooked ark didn't seem too inclined to
want to venerate me
but it was she was clear that that was
something that's happening and then she
said you are
basically you're the moon god
and i and my first react i had an
immediate
and rare initial reaction of humility
that was genuine where i was like i'm
not a god like even in the dream
and and
i said what you mean is i'm god-like in
the way that the moon is and she said
yes
your job is to shine light on the waters
mm-hmm now pedro you had something some
things to say about that well there's
there's a few things that i would i
would have to say
first off i think
i'm realizing how much this dream is
probably a reflection of a lot of the
reactions that i've also had from people
from all sides different conservatives
different
is the sense in which people felt like
we are in this we're in a moment of
crisis
and they felt like one of the things
you've been able to do
is to start building an ark
right to start build something which
would not be completely given into the
forces of of of the destabilization and
chaos that are happening and could maybe
kind of gather us together and carry us
through
towards something better and so the fact
that you have this flood we felt the
flood coming that's something i think
everybody kind of feels the flood water
is rising and so the fact that you see
that
this arc now isn't going to fly anymore
right and that that yeah it's got this
oligarch bureaucrat bureaucracy element
that's tilted and yeah and it's
incomplete and unfinished and so it's
contaminated by bureaucratic power and
and that is also which is also the idea
of the bureaucracy is also something
that is like their right-wing monster
right something that is structured and
and and uh hierarchical but it's not
working it's like this this and it's
dead it's the
beauty that the liberals
often have a claim on yeah right yeah
their conservatives have a claim on the
theoretical and abstract notion of
beauty and creating the conditions under
which beauty can flourish but generally
the liberals are the ones who create the
beauty is that fair yeah very often yes
okay and so and so then so then you move
out and
i think what's basically happening is
he's confirmed it's it's not exactly
fair as we were talking about earlier is
that without that liberal openness you
can't get access to that transcendent
realm from which beauty comes but we as
we discussed earlier the great artists
are actually a union between the liberal
and the conservatives what's
michelangelo they have that they have
that openness but they ally it with
discipline that's right and so then the
proper place of beauty is proper is is
that place you were at at the beginning
of the dream which is that idyllic
balance of
conservative limited lower case in the
humanities and monistic tradition
right for reasons that so we can discuss
at a separate time because i think that
the liberal arts education
foundationally we're talking about this
last night
is the is the
is the only solution for the insanity of
twitter and openness per se which is the
liberal temperamental virtue isn't
sufficient to produce creative
achievement it has to be allied with
action but just like i'm high
conscientious
which helps a ton
you're way higher openness than you've
been acting and so part of that i think
is like you almost first of all you you
died twice like you're put in a coma and
like it's like we're running out of
eastern european countries for you to go
die and die in right so
i mean and it's har
yeah it was
right
right and it was a horrible
run and tammy i mean it was awful
yeah what happened and so there's reason
for you to come out now
and be
unwilling or not willing incapable of
seeing like a newfound level of
vulnerability it's like you hatch
through a healing crisis and you have a
baby skin on and you're tucking into the
comforts of one side more let's say like
where you're being greeted and excited
yeah well it's a risk i mean when i've
when i've gone to washington to talk to
some of the people there
starting to talk more to republicans
because i've actually talked more to
democrats in the last five years than
republicans
even the republicans i'm talking to
say
don't
get co-opted by the republicans because
then you're just another republican and
it's not like they're a dime a dozen and
we need great republican leaders but
that's not
whatever i'm doing whatever that might
be it's just going to be a reduction of
that and so but it's also interesting
because well one of the things i have
noticed is that when i'm talking to
conservative types
i have to tread much less carefully
which is weird right because the
liberals hypothetically are the open
types but when i'm talking to democrats
i almost always feel and so do they that
we're both walking through a moral
minefield all the time
exhausting it is exhausting in a
particular way though don't
underestimate the extent of
openness and minefield walking for me
in my life to be able to get to a point
that i'm surrounded with people
in a whole weekend i'm not talking about
my community my community and family
conservative liberal we're squared it's
it's not relevant yeah but in a public
way of new voices
for me to get to a table with like james
orr and douglas hedley and
steven blackwood that's not that's not
you don't just roll in the conservative
town and get greeted with that there's a
lot of
coming from where though is it the
conservatives are coming after that or
the liberals
yeah are you are you more afraid of the
liberals that they're going to judge you
for talking to conservatives
both ways both ways the worst i've
gotten the worst anti-semitism and
deprecation and dehumanization has been
from the from the right when i've
appeared with you and with right there's
yeah there's no doubt well and i should
say but the last one is joke and so for
me it's like i i take arrows in the back
coming to the conversation the
conversations sometimes are difficult
and then i take arrows in the back from
them sometimes going back taking arrows
in the face as i'm going yeah yeah and
look jeff who cares i'm not saying well
you don't do it
but
it's hard on people it's hard but what
i'm saying is is like it's not a
it's hard to establish a group of
competent intelligent ethical people who
don't think like you it is hard but it's
still contingent on you to do yeah and
it might be hard in certain ways that
are specific to liberals which i get
because i see that all the time but
there's also different ways that it's
hard with conservatives yeah well the
problem too is you get tired yes like
one of the reasons i think that it's
been it's a relief to me
to talk to people
when it's not a minefield with every
bloody word right because it's just it
takes so much effort to negotiate that
and i know that that's i know that it
still has to be negotiated because the
alternative is conflict and war so but
but the temptation is there right
there's minefields a lot though like
i could hit a lot of notes wrong with
this group not now with like you and i
have a relationship now that's
like we understand it and it's not and
and black would too and or two right but
there's i could hit a note wrong
and find myself
yeah you know in a bunch of
where yeah well you can tell that
happens because it immediately descends
into the political that's right right
and then all of a sudden and then it's
not a good
and i'm like oh this is dead language
coming at me now yeah that's those dead
branches that cast a long shadow yeah
yeah so that's it's hard all the way
around i i'm you've had a uniquely hard
uniquely you've had a very difficult run
in ways that are unique to you that i'm
not trying to draw comparisons to but
well there's a moral hazard in that
because it's hard to keep equanimity in
the face of that especially when it
doesn't quit it doesn't stop that's
right and so what's hard is that ten
lawsuits against me right now on this
one that's like ten's a lot it is and
when it's
when it's when you're in the jaws of
of of a kind of kafka-esque crushing of
your
like the bureaucratic state having you
in its teeth with this power of the
state behind it is dizzying and
terrifying and resentment-inducing and
outraging yes
yes and it evokes like a murderous
murderous fantasy as a response
keep it up guys and see what happens so
here's the transcendence that's not good
so here's what you keep talking to
and imperfectly is fine and that's what
we're talking about but what you're
talking to is if you're traveling around
literally the world to talk about jesus
and to talk about the rules for
governing one's life and navigating
complex change
then you should be
i believe more open
to hearing when there are things to me
that are obvious missteps
i should be as open as possible well
obviously that's that's that's also why
we're having the conversation adjust to
it and that requires humility and part
of what was hard for me with the pride
comment you made for
elliot page was it was like you're
humble in all the ways that matter to me
but like
you have pride it's like that's like
call call elliot page dumb as a more
suitable insult from you it's like you
don't want to run around accusing people
of pride that's what depends on whether
they parade themselves on the cover of a
fashion magazine or not well you've
paraded yourself around plenty too yeah
but it wasn't to entice adolescent girls
to sterilize themselves well and is that
the question is is that in fact what she
was doing but nonetheless well that is
the bloody she's been on the cover if
that wouldn't have happened okay and
then she got 1.6 million instagram likes
and so i can't and maybe we could let's
talk about that seriously it's like okay
i cannot believe
as a clinician and as a psychological
observer
that one of the consequences of that
paradigm wasn't that at least one young
woman decided to sterilize herself
now i think it was likely a lot more
than one
but but i
i can't be certain that it was even one
but it's 1.6 million likes and we know
that the
incidence of gender dysphoria on the
young adolescent woman front has
exploded and i knew perfectly well when
all this pronoun nonsense emerged in
canada that that was what was going to
happen because i knew the literature on
psychogenic epidemics and i can't see
that elliot page didn't flip the switch
from victim to perpetrator with that act
and then stephen blackwood one of the
conservative guys that we've been
talking about president of ralston he
called me on that like you did in some
sense the other night he said you
bullied her you shouldn't have gone
after her that's a disproportionate use
of force and i thought that was a good
argument i thought that was a good
argument it's like i want to arrive at
this after the swimsuit yeah well we
should finish the dream too so okay just
okay so back to the moon image so
jonathan you had a comment about it i
don't think did you mention the moon i
don't think you have yeah exactly
so so so i think it's important to
understand in a way
the way that i see it is that
you if you feel like in the dream you
were confirmed
to be what you are yeah which is
let's say
something which is on the left the moon
in in terms of thinking is
definitely the left side even in
iconography the sun will always be say
on the right hand of christ and the moon
will be on the left the sun is the is
kind of like the origin and the moon is
the reflection but the moon is also that
which
changes the moon is changed the moon is
waxing and waning the moon is the
feminine that's right and so that's why
it's feminine that's why water has to do
with fluidity and change and
transformation so it's completely tammy
is saying you're a valid voice for that
and that's that's that's great that's a
great thing to have happen at the end of
that dream because you're called out by
the
loudest voice of the hillbilly right
that's the way the dream lays itself out
and then it's my wife
me being the loudest voice of the
hillbilly right in your dream and god
only knows to what degree that's true
period it's my wife who says no
you're shining the proper light and it's
a transcendent light right because
that's a very weird part of the dream
that you're allied in some sense with
the moon god so what the god part of
that is the transcendent part it's the
part that sheds line sheds light from
above and you're shedding light on the
water and i think i do think that's what
you're doing and i think you're doing it
extremely well i mean you're very
judicious and careful in your
articulation of the positions of the
left you know and you don't get
ranty about it pretty much never and you
you
you don't get prideful about it too and
i think that's partly because it's been
so bloody difficult and because you
actually didn't want to do it yeah but i
think the whole the whole and it's good
that tammy validates that it's amazing
yeah i'm so glad that i have such a
self-congratulatory dream like this
worked out very well for me because if
we did the one that shows that i'm like
impotent and crippled like and we did
that one and no no
no no but it is something to really take
heart from because the dream
the dream is very positively inclined
towards what you're doing and it's not
that it gets there easily right it goes
through the whole deadwood corruption of
western civilization incestuous
hillbilly the thing i would say is that
in the dream when i was joking saying i
had
like a rare but immediate moment of
humility i was positioned in the dream
with humility and it's like it's not
that's useful because the feeling tone
of the dream did like you know you have
dreams where that has to be the case
because if you if in the dream you would
have elevated your status to moon god
let's say by a narcissistic acceptance
you can be absolutely bloody sure that
would have been accompanied by
catastrophe because pride goes before a
fall that's right and we talked about
the great denzel washington line to will
smith that i think about a lot with
you where he said like right when you're
at your greatest like the devil comes
from right right and so i've been
thinking about that a lot and thinking
part of our conversation
now with your transformation through
literal death
it's like where are you gonna be now and
part of me is like henry the fourth is
over like attempt it's time for henry
the fifth
right some of those things have to be
left behind
in certain ways some of the rightnesses
of youth yeah well maybe twitter is one
of them you know because and it's very
convenient for me so my response to the
twitter ban wasn't of moral outrage in
fact it was first of all of of stunned
amusement that it happened to happen the
same day that i announced my
my partnership with daily wire i just
couldn't believe that was so utterly
ridiculous because one of the reasons i
felt that and we negotiated with the
daily wire for four months and my family
and i hashed that out because we didn't
not do this lightly and we paid
attention to every single word in the
contract and so we were on board with it
and
but one of the reasons for that was well
you know i might run afoul of one of
these major social media networks and
then well then what then what happens if
youtube stops me now we have backups and
all that but you get the point and then
it was so propitious insanely propitious
that the same day i put set this up
twitter said well you don't get to talk
to people anymore it's propitious it's
amazing it's jungian synchronicity for
me this one is
enough of the light i think i think it's
fine i think the dream is pretty i think
the dream is pretty clear i think that
anybody who's who who can think you can
understand that it is in some ways a
reflection of your reaction to to some
of the things that jordan has said and
also the idea that i think you always
view jordan as an ally in a way that you
tried to navigate between both sides
constantly to be careful and that you've
always seen that jordan has been that
for you you've had to defend him many
times to the left because you felt like
you could trust them you had your back
you're you're both able to talk across
the lines and now you're like oh wait
this is
yeah this isn't happening anymore like
wait this is breaking down to it he is
yeah there's a threat he is moving too
much into the into this side and so and
so then you are being kind of affirmed
as
it's like it's okay for me to be on the
left like even yeah
jordan going there it's like okay no i
can't let myself get pulled there i have
to be able to pull out smart and it's
like don't do a bunch of stuff
that affirms in in its minutia not as a
totality people's criticism that you're
like
a dumb person's idea of a smart person
yeah it's not true it's stupid well
actually i don't mind that so much in
some sense because right there's a
positive side yeah what i mean
with your role and and for me it's like
in your area of expertise like it kind
of boils down to what we're talking
about with the supreme court justices so
i don't get to say offhand things even
if i'm irritated on twitter
something like that well that could be
you can't maybe nobody
like the thing is so think i mean the
image that i have in my mind is let's
say from the outset you said something
like we're going to create a new
university we're going to create
something and then everybody was excited
and so now here comes peterson academy
yeah like this is possible yeah jordan's
going to be able to pull the best people
from everywhere and go is going to be
able to to create a university where
people are able to say the truth and
talk across lines and everybody's
excited and it's like i am a
conservative guy i'm a right-wing guy
yeah but i'm like i feel peterson
academy is way more important than
like these these kinds of partisan let's
say more partisan things even though i
know that i am
clearly on one side yeah so it's like
that's what i mean when i said at the
beginning that this seems to have
something to do with your role
was talking to us the other night and he
went after greg pretty pretty nicely it
was a very friendly way but reuben who
is more partisan and more provocative
and plays that role like shapiro does
for example um although
they both play more than that role but
they certainly play that role reuben's
objection to greg's criticism was that
well there is a time and a place to be
caustic and to be critical and to draw
distinct lines and he didn't
particularly feel sorry for the swimsuit
model who we haven't talked about that
much yet or for elliott page because he
felt that it was it was the right time
and place to
point out that that wasn't appropriate
and there's a lot of noise and and and
trouble associated with that but that in
itself doesn't mean that it's wrong and
dave's job
that he should do being true to himself
is to be that
and he's like a general yeah he should
hold that position for you he should
make me earn that at that table yeah
that's why he's there right
and he should also advise you in that
way so that you don't tilt too far and
so everything he said everything i was
like i actually completely agree
with a lot of what he said about it well
that's also why you're willing to use
wit and humor too because it's not like
you cut that out of your life well and
dave either david standoff yeah yeah
exactly so okay so we can figure that
out even if we disagree on a bunch of
stuff and usually what i tend to
disagree with on a bunch of stuff by the
way is what people say on twitter more
than who they are
which is also
because it's like really uh
and
but look so dave's doing what he should
do which is say to you like think about
all this stuff but i see you as having a
different role and it's precisely what
jonathan is saying
so how do you how do you embark how do
you embody the positive role
this is a weak
issue right so you're saying well it's
really good to offer the wheat and
that's the best thing but then you think
well yeah but you have to kind of point
out where the chaff is too but your
feeling is that it's way more important
to say here's the wheat than to
denigrate the chaff i do think that and
i but i do think also
a lot of the stuff was also about the
problem with the particular like i do
think that that was part of it
especially the swimsuit model issue
where it's like who's this girl like we
don't i don't know who she is and then
all of a sudden she becomes the the
whirlwind and and like we saw that
happen on the other side like think of
the covington kids and that kind of
stuff yeah we're completely outraged as
watching the media like destroy this
young man uh and whether it's in a way
it doesn't even matter whether it's it's
real or unreal or whatever but
ultimately when we so there's a there
was a feeling of that where it's like
this girl like we don't know who she is
and all of a sudden she becomes the yeah
i had less sympathy to be honest with
elliot page because i also think that
there was something way more
there was something bigger because she
is a celebrity and he is a celebrity
whatever like elliot is a celebrity
celebrity and there was something more
but the swimsuit model thing for me was
a little bit like oh okay okay
here's the role thing and i think this
is what this is where this is my
proposition that i want to put forth
that i'm fairly confident in but i'm
willing to have it like
it pecked to death by you
i think that you can have your
discerning great father tone
you can wear that more in areas where
you have expertise when you bring that
to
black supreme court justice or islam you
were out of your lane and your lane
there should be as a as a scientist and
a club
and an interlocutor but if you got so
there's one of my favorite jordan
moments was i put them on i always put
them on a chain with a bunch of
people were different thinkers and like
it almost always ends disastrously no
that's not true
it sometimes does but there's one point
we're going back and forth who's data
and who's data and who's expert there's
this like mirror game that everyone
plays from both sides well you're
experts wrong well your studies wrong
where you read the data wrong and it
just becomes this exhausting
mirrored conversation that jordan are
always trying to shatter but at one
point jordan said something about iq
testing and somebody was like well who
said that
and jordan was in one of his like you
must have been in an airport with tammy
losing your mind because jordan was like
i did i said it i have been studying
this field for 35 years i've published
200 peer-reviewed things i've like you
know i've created an entire company that
focuses on the testing i've cut the data
every way i've looked at it in any
conceivable way and basically it is a
topic on which
he is legitimately one of the world's
leading experts on it and you are angry
and it was like man fair enough i don't
care what your tone is i don't care that
you phrase it so you were like dead on
and you were well this gets us into
another problem too which is if we all
have to deal with global issues in some
sense right especially now because we're
increasingly globalized and the globe is
tilting in the way that that structure
in your dream was tilting but the
problem is is that all
we are all too ignorant to do that
and so one of the things i learned when
i worked on this u.n committee for
example which was the committee that
produced the report on sustainable
development for better for worse we like
to think that it was maybe a better
document
i mean we the people i worked with in
canada
but because we were involved
but it's still tangled it was part of
the process that tangled everybody up
into this globalist utopian catastrophe
that we're in at the moment so
so
um in any case one of the things i
learned is well no one knows how to do
this
you know how do we sustainable
development it's like well
oh yeah that's a good aim but the devil
is definitely the details and so you to
even address issues like this you have
to risk
leaping out of your bailiwick and so
there has to be a daring that's
associated with that but then the danger
is well what do you know enough about
the details and the answer is well well
so it's easy it's like what's the answer
to everything is more responsibility and
more humility and so the further you
move off your business like cocaine and
hookers
fitness
because you decide to become a
conservative so i talk to you like this
oh yeah oh yeah you want cocaine and
hookers
what is it responsibility and humility
right well so the further you are off
your base the more you have to be
cognizant yeah well and i get a lot of
comments like that on twitter you know
or on on youtube it's like well now
you're an expert in this and now you're
an expert like to me the the old one you
see 100 comments like that was like it's
like islam it's like really that's what
you're gonna wade into now and not run
it by like how many liberals not even
liberals is dumb because a lot of the
muslims in the world
who we need a lot right now are the
moderates
in the muslim world no maybe naughty
maybe not even the moderates you you
need the people who are willing to talk
and so one of the guys i talked to was a
leader who i'm who i'm going to talk to
again in the uk in the aftermath of this
message by the way good so he he's he's
a young leader of the more traditional
muslims and so
i wouldn't call them moderate yeah but
what was so cool because
he i had we went back and forth a lot
before we talked and i didn't talk to
him a couple of times because i was sick
and then
some bullying came out of that directed
to me and then i thought well if that's
going to be the situation i'm not going
to talk at all but then i thought well
those are his followers and forget it
and then he got the fight with douglas
murray which i wasn't very happy about
so i thought about scrapping the whole
thing and so he wants to get in a fight
with douglas
like the last person i want to get a
fight it's a bad idea so but i did go
ahead with the conversation and it was
kind of awkward and contentious to begin
with but what was so cool
the conversation straightened out we had
a real conversation but was so cool was
that
like a lot of people watched it and
most of them were muslim and a lot of
them were traditionalists and all the
comments were i'm so glad we're having
the conversation and so it's probably
not moderates exactly because that
implies a it's the wrong word let me
withdraw the word what i mean is that
moderates who have an interest in
free ideas and demar like the most
useful people for me right now to get a
handle on how to fix america
are
muslims
who
i mean so they're not hysterical when
things are happening right muslims it's
a it's a it's not a monolith it's like
latinos right like the big joke was that
biden won the latinx vote and trump on
the latino vote and it's like this
notion that latinos or monolith is in
like do you have mexican friends and
family talk to them then talk to their
parents then talk to their grandparents
like it's a no-brainer if you're off
twitter
the latino community is complicated and
there's all sorts of different
variations if you're cuban in
right anyways we don't have to belabor
it but with muslims there's a core set
of traditional values there's more of a
matriarchy in some of these cultures
than we would think from the outside
there's a very empowered role for women
to play
and so in the negotiation
muslim muslim women a lot they're
they're used to standing up within
negotiating with strong men as one word
but also strong men in a positive way
and that means they're really strong
women and it's it's like it's incredible
level of insight to be like oh so you're
trying to negotiate the balance between
freedoms and law and rights right now
we've been doing that for a while but
and so that's part of it where where
there's a there's an exposure into more
muslim thinkers of different stripes i
think that's very important
okay so i'm going to say in my own
defense
in some sense that i was willing to do
this badly because like what do i know
about greg slam i mean right and i i
can't even know about it in some sense
in some real sense because it's so
complicated and and to delve into it and
to become a master of the quran i mean
i'm not a master of the bible for god's
sake you know and so and then and so
i've had these conversations that the
span the islamic spectrum in some sense
because i talked to ayan herzeali
obviously who i really respect she's
she's a hell of a more incredible and
certainly from one perspective
but like to be completely admired for
her right courage and clarity and
intellect and strength like it's
staggering right and then i talked i
talked all the way through the islamic
political spectrum let's say to to
muhammad hijab who's on the
traditionalist end and who debated ayan
on my daughter's podcast
and so i've been trying to open myself
up to as wide a number of views because
there's no i just want to say one thing
is that i think that
there's a whole i'm going to talk to
muslims even if i do it stupid
there's a messaging and a context which
seeps back in which has something to do
with the dream i think and it has
something to do with the strange fact
that
you
you sign up with daily wire and then you
put out a message to muslims and that
cannot be ignored that the context of
that and everybody understands
positioning you keep commenting where's
the message to the jews yeah and i think
delete yeah but but i get to understand
i'm still waiting jordan yeah still
waiting
so here's the thing that's interesting
you guys can generate your own dab
message
like you have forever
we don't suck at storytelling no no no
um
yeah i mean okay so for me
the solution is that the solution is
what we're doing now
yes right but
how much of that has to be done post
talk like yes you know yes you know what
i'm saying is when you say okay so i did
i did it stupidly your humility and
willingness to sit here and have this
conversation
right and b
it's just because i think i can take you
in the final i know i know i know
i know
but but the willingness to do that to my
mind is all that's required and i want
to go through the other two tweets
because i do think that i would also say
look there's suggestions that i would
have about what type of positive
movement you could make on these three
fronts
but all that it is is that you can
progress boldly and be a fool
because the fool precedes the master
yeah and then accept
with humility that you should have had
greater responsibility and then you make
it well i don't think there's any other
way of doing it than that because you're
going to have to foreign
this part has been missing and it's been
a it's been a drum beat of one side of
that's exactly why we're having the code
that's right and so i knew it was
missing you know i mean with the elliott
page
front and i know we're going to get to
that in a minute because we still have
to return to sports illustrated no pezjo
you're dying to do that
but like part of what i said to you was
well why aren't you going after
um
women who get double d implants in
enterprise yeah right and your answer to
me was well they're not causing a
wholesale industry of whatever to happen
right but they are fomenting a porn
revolution that's decimating sexual
behavior and that was my point to you
yeah okay so fine do you wanna you wanna
come in
in a context that feels holy roller-ish
even against something that is fair and
that is problematic and doesn't have
nuance and doesn't have lines she's a 25
year old woman with 11 000 followers the
hard rule is if you have two
if you have billions of views and
millions of followers
you don't denigrate what her body looks
like on her specifically on twitter
which is asymmetrical warfare and then
complain that twitter's mean and retreat
from it again
well you know it's a funny thing to yeah
the second part of that i think is the
most relevant part is because
the way i handled it made it look like
the reason i went off twitter
hypothetically which i didn't exactly do
was because of the blowback from that
and that wasn't actually the case but
that was definitely a communication
problem on my part i mean it was part of
it you already said you'd be well you're
like i'm gonna be off i'm bigger than
this then you came in and you're
basically you're like the bad guy in
revenge of the nerds like who goes in
and there's like the big bone girl
having her moment at the prom and you're
like denigrate and humiliate her and
then left yeah if your point is to
sports illustrated look
what you're doing your sports
illustrated you're supposed to celebrate
the athletic body if she wants to be go
be a model for the next rubens good on
her
right she's having her own moment in the
sun right now and maybe there's some
pride in it but she's 25 and i promise
you she's not more prideful than you or
i at 25. so she's making her own choices
around this and trying to navigate the
difference between beauty and
self-esteem
and
what would you say health and
athleticism in her own life in a way
that makes her feel whole in a society
that's insane and the responsibility for
the society being insane is partially us
because we've failed to define those
terms sufficiently so she's 25 and
confused about that a little bit and
taking a moment where she feels she
participated in her own exploitation
um
definitely did that now you could say
even by the lights of the argument that
you just laid out is that that's
forgivable
at her age and with that opportunity
beckoning and why would you expect the
kind of wisdom that would be able to
negotiate that at that age and that
still doesn't justify the fact that you
went after and that you went after a
person
i think you're on worse ground than when
you said it's sports illustrated because
part of it you could say look let's say
you i am i think this is a weaker 15 it
is weaker i think right because it's
so when i talk to my daughter about this
for example she says yeah i don't feel
sorry for this girl because she's
putting forward an image of obesity as
positive and it's not positive and it's
not so were you outraged by this string
of endless heroin chic like white kate
moss models yes okay deal with people
that are right disorders great did you
then bring did you have access to
twitter that you brought the fury of the
incident
that was a while ago right but it
doesn't matter you have more
responsibility now and you brought the
fury of the world of the insane world of
twitter down on her head and you've had
that directed at you and it almost
killed you and she's a 25 year old woman
yeah and you brought that okay but then
you know what that is but then i would
say in defense to that it's that
and this is also part of what gets
tangled up in the liberal conservative
debate with regard to the moral high
ground part of the argument that you're
making is that i was mean to this girl
and i would say i think you can make
that case but then i would also say that
a line has to be drawn
and
it's very difficult to draw a line in
actuality without it also involving a
person who's involved in it so it's
pretty simple so it's pretty easy first
of all sports illustrated editorial
that's one they're an institution
second of all and by the way she's
following around having millions of
people now say nope sorry not beautiful
in her head i i know that but i don't
think that you get to say that it was
wrong because
because you feel sorry for this girl and
this is what happens on the left all the
time is that they point to the violation
of a moral virtue and they say okay
here's one here's where it
is but jesus things are falling apart so
fair so i get it i get it so whiny
empathy liberal argument let me take it
out of context you want to draw a line
women's bodies young women's bodies it's
complicated jordan right kind of like
like islam and
and
race in america it's a complicated topic
with a lot of hard feelings
you want to draw a line as a clinician
and with all of your you're starting
like a league of nations you're a
professor at 18 different places you can
publish a paper anywhere
is the plan if we bring together the
greatest think tank of geniuses liberal
and conservatives sit down to say what
you should do with this
is to go on twitter and with one second
of consideration right lambast somebody
because you're in nobody mood wait no
when you said you'd be off twitter and
your answer is well the article pissed
me off yeah right right right and then
you're so you can hide behind all the
liberals
but it's like look do it properly then
yeah right right and that's probably
well then you don't hide your your lack
of self-control and your inability to
control your disdain for something when
you turn into a moment drawing the
proper lines right and also like and
then call that liberal empathy weakness
good one yeah all right yeah yeah yeah
no no no i mean that gets us into an
a discussion i would say to some degree
about twitter per se
part of what we're laying out i would
say is twitter is not the place for
these discussions and so that opens a
broader question which is
is twitter a place for any discussion
about anything twitter anymore so let's
say let's let's we let's say you're
it's so
it's so funny because
people pay you so many compliments and
so it's funny when i like have to in the
course of making arguments it pains me
so much as it should it's like when i
beat you at most things it's just
painful
but okay so you're one of the great
minds of a generation you have a
transformative intellect you have an
ability to frame things in a way that
make people
see things through epiphany that is
altering we've talked about the
difference between the semantic and the
procedural and how you get things in a
ritual you know how to do that
you're occupy if you're on twitter you
are insane you are dealing with a
monster that you don't know what it is
clinical curiosity okay doc yeah like
jonathan hate manages to act like an
adult but he's on facebook
he he studies twitter i know but he's
but his primary deal i i'm not making an
excuse but his primary domain of
concentration is facebook and facebook
for all its insanity is not as insane as
twitter that's true but also twitter
suits your temperament because he's got
a more even temperament than you yes he
does i haven't picked the most toxic
right social media and it's like it's
like a video game where you're like oh
we don't know who's on here it's a mind
control game let me go on there and
cause
of the discourse in the public to be
about me playing a stupid addiction game
an elliott page thing when it devolved
into and i get this email chain it's
always when jordan does something
like
what i would call dumb but you know call
it ill-advised or or maybe other people
think it was great nonetheless something
pronounced let's just say like all of a
sudden my phone explodes because
everyone's like what
what's this idiot doing now it's like
jordan drank moonshine and got the dog
pregnant it's like it's like where is he
like go find this guy right it's like
it's a disaster
anyway so everything's like blowing up
about this and then i'm on these chains
i was in some meeting
you really are an awful person i know
fundamentally there's no doubt about it
but so i come out of this thing and it's
like i'm on this chain with like
like you know who are we going to gather
up to be against freedom of speech and
it's like every thinker imaginables on a
chain and how do we get to elon it's
like and it all was so performative to
me and then you're like i'd rather die
than take down the tweet and it was like
jordan you're in a video game that's
designed by teams of addiction
specialists to
skew your opinion a bunch of ways and to
make you angry and outraged and to make
you represent views and say things in
captured language that's offensive to
the other side to drive polarization
further that's the medium yeah
it really is hard to say
just exactly how dangerous twitter is i
mean one of the things i've very much
noticed is that on twitter people
regularly say things
like
and this just happens it's constant
people say things on twitter that are so
outrageous
they would never say them even once face
to face
to anyone in their whole life like you
to that swimsuit model you would never
say that to a 25 year old woman in my
own defense i would say i wasn't saying
it to her
but i was saying it to the people who
insist that we accept a particular
standard of beauty that has nothing to
do with beauty in order to advertise
their moral superiority at being
tolerant great so you did that 140
characters as well you think no no i
don't so and is that like the
interpretation of the world
no the interpretation of the world is
she got blown up
no no that isn't all that happened
though because there was also that is
one thing that happened that's one of
the things but you made a choice with
one second delay so there's different
responses
so ellie parties
subversion of duty but it was clearly a
marketing decision on their part they
made a youtube video where they show how
they tell her that she's on the cover
and obviously everybody's surprised and
they're filming her being surprised
because they know that this is a
marketing ploy to virtue signal to the
world so do so do both then it's like
look for me it's like which dog do you
feed right you have justice jackson she
said one thing you thought was dumb
you've said just by dint of this
conversations a score of things that i
think are dumb probably some in the
conversation itself well and me too
right it's like you could go back and
rewind this and right write me a manic
email the night and take the moonshine
dog comments yeah example
it was the moonship
let's not bring it back up
how about that oh yeah yeah that one
we'll cut that and that doesn't need to
go out on the daily wire i don't after
we talked about showing greater
discretion
um but look part of that is the point
though because one of the things you
said that i thought was valid is you
said look you have to work up a certain
amount of vehemence to go up against the
world and that's true with this
conversation with me and part of it is i
was like look i can't not make jokes
that i i mean yeah i could if i was
better than i am no no i have to shut up
ahead of doing that and well i have to
get up ahead of steam yeah and it
doesn't mean i feel that vehemently in
some great moral sense there's tons of
you come back constantly and cut down my
argument to to size as you should but so
part of what you were saying is there's
a certain amount of vehemence that i
need to enter the marketplace especially
especially newly out of a healing crisis
in which you die well with these
pre-prepared
uh
more journalistic pieces that i've done
some of with the daily wear i was doing
them before i read them and people are
less happy about that in some sense you
know because it's not spontaneous but i
want to think through the argument
partly to address some of the issues
we're describing but then for example i
i recorded one this week which was a
criticism let's say of the trudeau
government and there's like 100
criticisms in the article and it's very
it takes very much effort to lay out an
argument like that that's a hundred
criticisms and then to face down the
government in some real sense and it's
very difficult to do that without
building up somewhat of a head of steam
it's like because it'd be easier just to
lay in bed and so read it let's read a
stephen king novel or something much
easier which is like the best thing that
we should all be doing right now instead
of this
however
um
i totally agree and so the standard for
me and that's the balance between what
reuben was saying was was wisely saying
right because the point isn't that we
cut you down
to size and we take your rough edges off
and we moderate you that's what people
think with moderation yeah well that's
the compromise issue but we don't want
to compromise we want transcendent and
transcendent is if you think long enough
you get to something that the majority
of same people can agree on and
subjugate themselves to
to have something to aim at
and that's the work that needs to be
done so if you take a misstep because
you're human
and because you're doing stuff that's
incredible and because you're under an
amazing amount of pressure and because
at different times your brain's broken
or revved wrong all that matters is is
the humility which you're doing
to
address the complexity of it and not do
one of those like hostage prison fake
apologies but like there's a certain set
of things that you could do to say like
maybe you do owe that young woman an
apology i don't know it's something to
think about what's the most important is
is that you're willing to hear the fact
that you should and entertain that as a
realistic option you can do whatever you
want they see
i scoured my conscience i would say on
this twit these tweet fronts in some
sense and i had the same response in
some ways that you did in your dream
which is i didn't feel guilty but by the
same token
i didn't feel that i had done it
optimally
right and so and the issue here is these
things and maybe that's and you can't
approach yourself and you won't
apologize to a mob if you apologize to a
mob you're a coward yeah
right
also and don't apologize
apologize to the same mob because it's a
mob it's fluid it's like these mosquitos
yeah it's like oh i will outsource an
apology to a bunch of people who i don't
know and who are not democratically
elected as representatives of their
party who it's like when people
criticize me for something that i feel
it's like really over the
like
15 people who are of somewhat like
mind in my community who i have like
trust and relationships with who
criticize me way more vehemently than
that i'm going to outsource this to you
that i'm supposed to apologize to you
and you're probably not even real yes
exactly and so that's the specific
versus the general like
i have better critics than you no that's
right yes right
that's right you think you're critics
right like someone knows like
yeah whenever i that's right yeah jim
right with his like sunshine and
unicorns the gym it's like jim tell me
what you think but just like right
trying like you need matt you need like
zofran before you ask jim for advice but
so
right and so part of it is is that we're
you can but there are some
so it's like well what's the difference
between apology that's performative and
stupid and something that is separating
the wheat from the chaff and it's also a
show of proper respect which is okay you
talk to muslims not optimally you talked
about race in america not optimally you
talked about the supreme court justice
not optimally given that you can't just
flee the institutions and only talk to
people who've been rejected by the
institutions among whom there's amazing
people you have brett weinstein you have
teams james orr is not rej you know what
i mean but close enough right but i mean
you have incredible people
we also aren't we i don't think you we
want to decimate all the institutions
like definitely if you want to go back
and revive that's when you get into a
dangerous what i would say is a
dangerous right-wing populism and i've
been talking to the conservatives about
that it's like you cannot come out and
say well the institutions are
retrievably corrupt and that's certainly
one of the dangers of the trump side of
the populist right so what so what would
be something like this is me
thinking not giving a directive so you
don't go make some apology and be like i
didn't understand race in america and
i'm sorry and i'll read more tony
morrison and fox yeah right it's like
who cares but what you could do is to
take steps to ensure that justice
jackson
who whether you agree with her not and
whether you agree with all the political
idiocy that surrounded her and maybe one
dumb answer
is received in company that's around you
with the due measure of respect and
admiration that she deserves and
deserves to be disagreed with on other
tenants
that's the thing that's owed for i think
well you and i have been look you and i
have been trying to do those sorts of
things where we have the ability because
we've been trying to bring
respectable democrats
into the conservative discussion and i
would say and you can say what you want
about this because i'd be interested to
hear but i think we've had more trouble
finding democrats who are willing to do
that then we've been having trouble
finding conservatives who will invite
them to do that
certain conservatives on the invite have
no trouble with a whole tranche of
conservatives there's certain red lines
it's very hard to draw people across to
that that's
i think much easier i think we should
not go into that so shall we close up
with the elliott page
tweet
i think that we've talked about it all
through yeah we have and and i think
that i don't know i don't know if
there's more to really add well so so
here's with me i mean choose your words
carefully yeah choose your words
carefully criminal physician has a bunch
of connotations
if you're is it a criminal physician if
somebody gets
their face tattooed 500 times if they
get implants all over their body there's
a million things that well that's a good
deal that's a good question and that
that's a whole separate discussion right
because you have a not really because
you're picking one out and you're not
looking at the others just like you did
with justice jackson well you can't look
at all them at the same time but you
look at one set particularly
mostly recently yeah and it's of a
direction i know i know that but it's
also the case that it's in that set is
causing a tremendous amount of trouble
the first look greg i knew
when the pronoun bill came out
i knew
that for every trans kid that was
hypothetically saved
we would doom a hundred confused
adolescent females because that had
already happened on the anorexia front
it was like if you knew the literature
it was obvious what was going to happen
and so this this is there is an element
of the argument that's like well where
do adults have the right to draw the
line with regards to their own surgical
transformation
perfectly reasonable thing to debate to
what degree can physicians be complicit
in this because there is a there is a
hippocratic oath problem there it's just
because someone wants a porn's implanted
in their head which people have had done
doesn't mean the physician has a moral
right to do that and i know that those
lines have to be drawn and the the issue
with regard to surgical enhancement say
sexual surgical enhancement is also
another borderline but this is there is
a line here it's like
we're enticing young people with this
fluidity issue we're enticing young
people to sterilize and mutilate
themselves and not just a few a lot and
and the incidence has skyrocketed to the
point where yesterday the day before the
uk closed its primary gender
transformation clinic it's like so
this is not just a
difference in
degree with the difference
with what with porn it's kind
porn is decimating yeah right we're
right right but i don't think it's
reasonable to say that i shouldn't have
gone after the trans minor problem
because i didn't simultaneously go after
the porn problem i don't go after a
trans minor problem in a way that made
any sense because you don't know okay
well i'm sorry let's say
like elliott page
is not a rapid onset gender dysphoria
convert who spent too long at marlboro
school in l.a maybe
um this may be okay i don't believe so
we have we can i think you could make a
case that that
he isn't
but
he did it when when this was not trendy
he did it when
ellen page walked away from a lucrative
right but people can be unbelievably
confused for a very long period of time
and and the mere fact that it's been a
long time that they've been confused
doesn't mean that they've thought it
through when they make their decision
and i would say it hasn't been thought
okay anyone wouldn't have been public
that's the thing it's like okay
everything you think through wrong is
public and we're having a whole
conversation about the fact that you
make mistakes right but here's enticing
adolescent girls to sterilize themselves
okay but are you enticing when you make
that comment about a swimsuit model
young men who worship you and think that
you're saint-like to act like pigs to
women no but i might be encouraging them
to not respect the things i'm saying
because i'm being uncautious and i would
say even if the sovereignty true with
elliot page
okay yeah but the the it's the
consequences yeah
it's like it's like look you had
you had your psychological problems
whatever they might be i'm not going to
argue about what they are um you
rectified them in a very very dramatic
way and perhaps that was your right and
perhaps it was the right of the surgeons
although i'm not convinced of either of
those things by the way it may be the
case but i'm not convinced of it but
then
you made it not only public but
triumphantly public
i finally found my true self and i'm a
model for emulation it's like i don't
think so
i don't think so but if he did
do you believe anyone is trans
i wouldn't like with all the variations
in the world including i know the answer
that question
someone comes to me and asks me that
question because people have asked me
those questions and the answer is we
need to talk about it for 5 000 hours
that's the answer okay so and so okay
because who knows what someone really is
i mean none of us know who we really are
so if do i believe that
that men can be born in women's bodies
i certainly don't believe that statement
is is in any way an adequate
representation of either the problem set
or the solution here's an example do you
believe that anorexic women who think
they're too thin are too thin because
they sure think they are
and i really i do not see how that's not
analogous
and you know we wouldn't have
so for me this is where it tacks to the
personal yeah where i have a friend a
family member
who
lesbian
working class
mexican
really funny really irreverent yeah
um
went through therapy master's degree two
years of therapy yeah calmly decide a
huge fan of yours yeah
listens to you every night
went through transition
only questions that he came to me with
were how
how do i be a better man because i
always say it's hard enough to be one
gender to do one gender well half of us
aren't doing it right it's hard enough
to be gay and then if you want to switch
gender
and to me in this in this individual
yeah and i i don't want to get into
stats and numbers
because it's it's a different argument
and i'm and i probably can't keep up
yeah this person is the fullest
embodiment of who he is meant to be and
it's somebody i know intimately maybe
well as much as you could judge any as
much as you are for me in my eyes so
whatever my opinion estimation is worth
well okay that'll switch things into a
slightly different so argument i'm
willing to accept that because i already
if that's an acceptance then again wait
a sec there's okay there's contingency
okay
if in finding your true identity you
violate a cultural norm that's so
profound that you destabilize the old
the entire country the entire culture
then maybe you don't have the right to
do that even if it actualizes yourself
but i don't know right it is the manner
of twitter right like how many people
who are not activists
are you engaged with regularly with
their opinions
in the public marketplace of ideas like
not a lot right there's a bit they
haven't had
a full negotiation with the american
public yet right there's no harvey milk
there's no
martin luther king like it's a it's a
conversation that hasn't happened well i
don't even know
that that branch of the
lgbtq plus community should be
conceptualized in that manner that's the
thing that liberals do immediately this
is another civil rights battle it's like
yeah oh no maybe but maybe not but what
i'm saying is is well maybe but maybe
not gets proven if somebody can come
forth who appropriately negotiates with
the culture
acceptance in a manner that is moral and
by moral well it doesn't mean okay so
john lewis another problem that's
emerged out of this that's very very
complicated it's like okay so now the
trans community is brought into the
realm of normativity in some sense let's
say and so now and so here's where the
wheel that wheel hits the road so now
you're a 10 year old and you're you're
wondering about your gender identity and
your sexuality or maybe you're 11 and
you're confused because maybe you're a
pretty feminine boy and maybe you're
tilted biologically towards being
homosexual and now the conversation is
well maybe you should be castrated
and the answer to that question is
yeah maybe that'll happen yeah and then
there's another question that comes up
is like
so is it so clear that the gay community
is better off under the aegis of the
trans umbrella than they were under the
ages of the monus
of the heterosexual monogamists and the
answer to that seems to me to be not
only are they not better off they're way
way worse wait there's one more thing
there's one more thing
the the inclusion violates the ideal and
the norm and you think well that's
necessary because then it includes but
one of the consequences might be that if
you extend the ideal so that it's too
inclusive you blow the ideal so that
it's even worse for those yeah
marginalized yeah and i really do think
that's happening i know that and this
battle i do too
i do too and i agree with everything
that you've said about the complexities
and the thing that is the hardest is the
removal of counsel
teachers physicians everybody
psychologists who are no longer no
longer allowed to have these
conversations sometimes say well how do
i know they're not allowed to have these
conversations and the answer is because
i have 10 lawsuits against me that's
right for having these conversations
however badly i'm having them so so now
we are surgically transformed children
that we are not allowed to talk to yes
and i think that elliot page
aided and abetted that
okay
and pridefully so there's two
conversations that we're having and it's
important to break it down so one of
them is in me saying do you think
anyone's trans there's not a clear
answer you can get for that i have a
different opinion that i believe that
there are people that that is their
fullest most embodied self that's my
opinion you don't need to share it
well i would just say i don't know
because i have to talk to so great so
then so talk to them and i mean people
have all sorts of weird identities you
know so god only knows but so part of it
for me and then there's the whole issue
of how it's moving through the culture
which i do not want to defend because i
don't agree with that so i don't want to
get pulled into a defense from me saying
this of you saying well that's what you
liberals do all the time you bring it in
and you normalize it and you pull it and
then you decimate what the norm is i'm
saying well there's no i'm saying some
advantages to to bringing in the margins
into the center to the degree that you
can manage what i'm saying is it has
that is a conversation that has gone too
fast given twitter in the pace of
conversation like if you're blowing up
dave chappelle
right right right and dave chappelle is
like especially for that comedy
performance did you listen to it you
think he's anti-trans are you utterly
clueless i would never hesitate to have
dave chappelle at my house with my
transgender godson at the table and
think it would be anything he's like the
most soulful gesture of the court and
you can't you can't cut down the court
jester because they're the source of
wisdom and saying things that aren't
allowed to be said yeah and you don't
get to cut the line in front of
everybody else to do it either but part
of that is also like with your issue
well who's democratically electing that
leadership to criticize him well no one
it's like who knows what anybody thinks
about anything so that's part of why i'm
saying i don't want to wear and have an
argument with you
about the entire movement of
trans through the culture and all the
ways that that's being mismanaged
because we're in agreement on a lot of
yeah but i'm saying if there is an
absolute version of it then again
landing here from outer space and you
get to pick your team of experts that
this is something you want to discuss as
a world the most famous psychologist in
the world
yeah well i think part of the moral of
the story is
and this and this might be the
fundamental issue is twitter is not the
place to have a discussion about
seriousness and when you said it i
didn't i mean i think maybe because we
we did want to write we should yeah we
should wrap up one thing in and then i
want to wrap up okay and so how you did
it was imprecise because it was like
everyone was confused about us if you
want a real solution in some ways i
think any real solution has to involve
both instead of just like crushing and
subverting yeah so who would be a really
interesting conversation like this one
for you to have is if you and elliot
page reset in another have someone in
the uk okay and you're willing to say
you know what it's like if i take you at
your word of what it feels like to be
trapped in the wrong body
here's kind of what's happening are you
what are your concerns that's what i did
with reuben on the issue of gay parents
that's right it's a missed opportunity
to do the thing that you
are in many regards best suited to do
which is say okay well where's your line
and where's my line and here's a bunch
of concern and you have concern too if a
bunch of kids if there's a wave of rapid
onset gender dysphoria and a whole bunch
of kids are having hormonal conversions
that are irreversible before the ready
you don't want them stuck in the wrong
body what's the balance where do you
think the balance is
yep
pulling out from the details of the
different tweets and the different
messages that have come out
i think that one of the things that greg
is expressing and i think that there are
actually you would be surprised to know
that
he's not just expressing it from the
left like there's also i know
conservative right-wing people that have
expressed some just a concern
about role and that is something that
you have to decide also what your role
is because the way in which many of us
perceive you
is a role which is able to raise to be
raised up above the fray of politics
without being afraid of getting into
politics but he's able to raise up above
the fray of politics and is able to kind
of cross over and
disarm each side to a certain extent
because the manner in which you have
people don't realize this but the
management manner to which you have
de-radicalized people that were moving
in a frightening way towards the right
and the manner in which you have pulled
people who thought that that people who
were going also in the left and they
didn't know where they were you were
able to kind of tell them look this is
not what you think like you you can you
can think certain ways and it doesn't it
doesn't you've been able to to really
act as that strange pivot and so so i
think that in a way if there's a lot of
weight on you
it's very heavy
but i think that maybe that is what
you're seeing it's not as heavy as doing
it wrong yeah but maybe that's what
you're seeing is you're just seeing this
call of people saying look if you fall
into
into the pundit we're gonna lose that
which we love the most about jordan um
and so yeah just say be attentive is the
only thing
and you know what the left doesn't
realize
and the means let's say the neg the the
part of society that doesn't understand
or judges jordan in ways that are unfair
rather than fair so negative judgment
is the amount of work he's done
pulling people out and criticizing the
alt-right like that's been a huge role
right and if you're on this side of the
fence everyone's like he's creating the
alt-right he's participating in positive
masculinity and enforced monogamy that
doesn't have the meaning that anybody
thinks that it has
but there's whole podcasts where you're
speaking to the alt-right in a manner
that is that is
unbelievably
critical and offering a different path
out and you had one person who wrote you
a letter last time we were there that i
don't think you've talked about publicly
a high school a high schooler who
literally was going to be a high school
shooter who said i was going to go shoot
up my high school
and i listened to you and i didn't shoot
up my high school and i thought and got
help and
was in appropriate hands at that point
and i thought
that's a that's like a
that's a piece of script like that the
importance of that thing that happened
it's like so literally there now are a
number of families in a whole community
whose kids weren't murdered as a result
of that
and so if there's certain things people
are worried about you always say if you
if you
right if you're afraid of weak men i'm
sorry if you're afraid of strong men you
should be terrified of what weak men can
accomplish
and so that's the part of it and so
that's why these these small
seemingly small
um
corruptions in the facade where it's
like you're not being gentlemanly you're
not being this it feels nitpicky in the
face of so much of what you're doing but
it's no no the details matter details
matter that's why elliot page and the
swimsuit model matter that's right
they're not just details that's right
and you getting that right is important
because the more that people on the
right who have said hang on a minute i
was going alt-right i don't want to go
all right i don't want to go far right
and part of that's jordan peterson and
people on the left who said i don't want
to go far left i'm i'm liberal i'm still
going to stay liberal but there's a
whole bunch about him that pulled me out
and moved me for towards transcendent
values responsibility
right um responsibility more than and
humility that was you and humility right
and
love good community yeah well that's so
challenging with this conversation
that's right
responsible humility on both our parts
on all of our parts is to engage in the
discussion of good faith and see if we
can figure out how to do this better
moving forward jonathan's been
insufferable but i think we did a good
job on that front
all right thank you sir thanks thanks
greg and it's definitely a tribute
i think in the end it is a tribute to
you that you're even willing to do this
i agree we appreciate it yeah well i'm
more terrified of the alternative than
of the conversation and that's
definitely the case
so
all right thank you all who are watching
and listening and uh
appreciate the time and attention and to
the daily wire crew
that's also much appreciated thank you
that's wrap
gentlemen